[Music]
it was the round after the rest day and
the clock was ticking down for eight of
the world's best players looking to make
a move of the standings
pre-tournament leader maxine bashir
lagrav took a devastating hit from
alexander grishik but it was a surging
anish giri whose crushing win against
ding loren
placed him just a half point behind ian
naponniachi
with three rounds to go the
thoroughbreds are rounding the bend with
the finish line in sight
round 12 coverage of the candidates in
yekaterinburg russia
starts now
[Music]
welcome everybody to round 12 of the
candidates the tournament is taking
place at the beautiful hyatt regency of
yekaterinburg
and what a tournament it has been one
for the history books
with the last the first half being
played last year but
guys it is almost the finish line
my name is alejandro ramirez and i am
here with grand masters maurice ashley
and yasser sarawan
to bring you all the action yasser what
do we got so far
well uh we've got a really really really
tough tournament and we knew it was
going to be a tough tournament from the
very start
and it's been a tension-filled
tournament but we do have a
clear runaway leader right now nepo is
looking
really good who can stop this man
there's two
chasers but i tell you maurice
to my mind you know big big favorite
nepo at this moment
no question about it especially with
that tie break edge
all the way from round one defeating
anish giri who knew that would have
such an important effect on the
standings right now
and yes indeed there's got to be some
victories if they're going to catch him
nobody's going to do you any favors and
just lose games
the players chasing him will have to
take destiny into their own hands
and let's take a look at those standings
as we see jane pogniacci with seven
points
now this is only a half point lead over
the dutch
anish giri but as you mentioned maurice
it's that tiebreak advantage
what tie break head to head that is the
biggest and most important tiebreak of
this tournament
and in round one jane pomnyacci defeated
annie's gear with the black pieces
and that's what's giving him in
practical view a full point lead
over the dutch following anishikiri is
fabiano carrano with six points
uh maxima sherlock and alexander grisham
with five and a half have
an outside perhaps mathematical still
chance of making it to the podium but
first place it's gonna be tough they're
gonna have to score a lot of wins in a
row
meanwhile wang hao kiril alexenko
surprisingly they're at the bottom
dingler and
they really don't have any chances to
get their ticket to
dubai and challenge world champion
magnus carlsen
let's take a look at the format of the
event it's a double round robin as we
mentioned the first half was played
last year and we resumed this year with
round eight
and on very classical chess very slow
100 minutes for the first 40 moves 50
minutes for the next 20
15 minutes added on move
60. a 30 second increment all throughout
no draw offers before black's 40th move
to ensure
that every game is fighting chess and a
prize fund that as we've mentioned
pales in comparison to that spot to
qualify for the world championship match
and the schedule we have around today
and then the second rest day will be
tomorrow the tournament will resume on
monday april
26 with game 13 and will probably be
finished
off on april 27th with game 14. there is
the chance of playoffs if
somehow there is a mathematical tie
in the solomon burger and the
head-to-head and the amounts of games
won
but that is difficult to believe we do
not expect a playoff
in this tournament we'll be calculating
all of those possibilities
as we get closer to the finish line but
of course
we have important games today maurice
what is going on there at the top
well there are three players who think
that they can win it the three
musketeers
and everybody else is just begging for
victories
but we have to take a look at the
realistic possibilities here
and let's start with fabiano caruana the
previous candidate the challenger
to magnus carlsen in 2018
not looking like a real challenger if
you look at his line score
only two wins and one loss
this is not how you get it done he's
gonna have to start
getting some wins quickly he's only got
three rounds to go
and as you see these three players he
has left geary
wang and grisha he drew them the first
time around
that cannot be the line score this time
he probably needs
two wins out of these last three games
if he's gonna have
any realistic shot at beating out
yande pumnachi the next player also
is going to need some victories we will
mention anish geary losing in round one
as you see there against jan nepamechi
but after round six he's been a boss
that's what you look like when you're
trying to win the candidates three wins
and three draws
he probably needs a couple more wins if
he doesn't want any
outside help if he's going to overcome
that tie break disadvantage can he get
it in these three games well he's got
bobby right now with the black pieces
then he's got another block
against chris a very tough opponent that
last round
his handlers are thinking you better
beat the bottom seed if we're gonna get
it done
so he's got to try to somehow eek out a
win
in one of these first two games the
player who doesn't have to think about
any wins whatsoever is this man janna
nepamnichi
and this is the line score of a champ
four wins
one loss definitely contentious fighter
this guy incredible tournament so far
and he just needs to get three draws in
the next three rounds
and that probably will seal the deal
unless somebody comes up with some
hot play but three draws look at how he
did against
the three opponents that he that he is
scheduled to play
right now wang hao he beat him the last
time around then he lost to vashila grav
and he defeated dinglerin so i don't
expect
any simple draws coming out of this man
he wants to be the champion can he get
it done we will see
guys there's got to be victories it's
the only way
if they're going to catch napoli because
he's just
looking right now like the odds-on
favorite
and let's take a look at the whole stand
uh pairings for today's
round twelve alejandro a huge round
right there fabiano caron against
anishikiri
as you mentioned if i was white he just
he has the press ding around with the
white pieces against alexander
grissom probably not the most relevant
for the standings
maxine vasherla graf meanwhile with the
white pieces he wants to get is
mathematical
possibility is still up there he will
have to defeat
uh kirill alexenko who plays with the
black pieces
i must win game for mvl but even then
he's still on the outside looking
in meanwhile wong hao with the white
pieces no real chances to take this
tournament but
can he play spoiler he does have the
white pieces against jan ne pony
pognachie the leader
of this tournament jan i'm sure we'll
try to be ultra solid
in this game yasir take us through
what's happened so far today
exactly well we'll pick up the action
for this round 12. this position was
reached earlier in the round
nepo playing his russian defense
came out of the opening looking really
good very very solid position
for black he's given up the advantage of
the two bishops but because
of the closed nature of the position uh
white's advantage is just a smidge here
nepo came up with what i thought was an
interesting plan it's like
if you were in a situation where you
had to win then the moves rook c8
and c5 definitely play into that
attitude i've got to win this game as
black i've got to win this game as black
but if your attitude is you know what am
i talking just a draw
you start to think well i should play h5
i should take and i should put my rook
on the opened
h file interesting approach by nepo he
doesn't back down from the challenge
i personally would have played h4 traded
off the h-bonds and
looked for more trades down the h-file
he played rook c8
at yeah he played c5 i mean
okay taking the bull by the horns and
this is where
things currently stand again you know
the two bishops
whites trying to do something i suppose
uh but it looks like uh just uh
i'm gonna say a draw in the offing here
the real yeah
yeah i just want to make a point and i'm
gonna look it up while you do that
i specifically remember one magnus
carlson doing the exact same plan
to this exact same structure i don't
remember the game i'll try to find it
but i remember
when i saw it as i said playing c5 and
just messing up your pawn structure
accepting
the isolated pawn in an end game so
maybe nepal has that position in mind
okay and well that would that's a page
out of the world champions book there
but c5 uh forcing play uh the
for me the game of the round is
definitely between
fabi and anish it's a sicilian
featuring an early 8-3 the players have
reached this position
i've been playing around with the
position i just think that it's balanced
it's just very tough for white to get
anything
back here we just saw the move king h1
by white and the idea is to get out of
queen b6 check followed by queen takes
b2 you can certainly capture this bond
but when your king is on g1 queen b6 is
the problem
here i would expect to move queen b8
attacking the pawn on b4 but more
like x-raying the e5 square
and getting off the d-file what's the
idea b2 or b3
take your pick and then the knight just
plops itself down on
e5 and says go ahead and do your worse
as white so i think this game is very
balanced
obviously as you were saying at the top
of the show marie's players need
victories
and a draw actually hurts both players
in this game somebody needs to win
dingler in versus
alexander grishok going to go back a few
moves
back to this point i must say i've seen
a lot of
games by the very very top players
including the candidates
previous candidates with this line of
the slop
i never really understood what it was
all about
white has some space yes but
i think the position's really balanced
after queen c2 b5
rook fe1 i see a lot of trades coming
a b a b rook a7 and
a very balanced game finally the game
that french fans are pining for
is between mvl and carol
carol has been generous to put it mildly
and
at this exact moment i really do like
mvl's game uh a lot uh
how big an advantage i'm i'll put it at
like a one point advantage the two
bishops
open position but even more importantly
white has even an
edge in development and a real weakness
here on
f7 that black has to carefully guard
so of all of the games at the moment it
seems to me like mvl
is the is the single player who's
emerged from the opening with an
advantage
it's an interesting thing to compare
these pair of bishops to the other right
because also has the pair of bishops and
we're saying okay what is the pair of
bishops advantage
in chess and it really depends on the
power of them
not only just the power right now but
the potential power
of the bishops and you can see the ones
that mvl has right now monsters
they cross they just cross the board
they're killing any type of counterplay
they're hitting f7
they just do great things and they're
controlling black's pieces
the pawn structure is learning itself as
well it's asymmetrical
which means that we have the possibility
of opening the position even further
down the road
compare that to one house bishops right
which are discoordinated
they're not really cutting the board and
the structure in that position with an
isolated pawn
and some weaknesses doesn't really let
the bishops shine it's nice that we have
the side to side back there
we in which you can see right the
bishops of one side is just completely
different in the bishops of the other
right the other thing i would just throw
in there just to
uh buttress this idea that the you know
the bishops are really not producing
it's this knight on f1 right this knight
on f1 was for example
on the g5 square or you know
forcing this diagonal open
like somehow challenging this knight on
e6 yeah i mean we we might warm up to
white's
task but because the knight is passively
on the f1 square
it's another reason why i kind of
i don't feel the power of the bishops
another thing that's basically hanging
over the position is this move d4
if the move d4 invites takes you
better make sure that there's no
uh nothing bad or untoward happening
after rook c2 that's point number one
the other point is
i'm not really a big fan of playing this
move
c3c4 whenever i see these structures
where
i've got a pass pawn on d4 and i've got
a knight on c5 that can't be kicked by
b4
i begin to get happy for black so um
at this moment after the move rook b1 i
think
a critical line is d4 and it's not the
only move you can also
simply get out of this pin with a move
like rook c6
give me your guys best judgments how do
you uh
if you were to put a point system on one
to ten
uh five being dead even right
or hold on how do i wanna do it you know
what i'm asking
who would you rather play yeah thank you
um yeah we can all agree it's in a
balanced position the question is would
you rather take black or white in this
position
exactly um probably black right
and you uh marie's jump in here with
uh your opinions too would you in a
practical game i mean your clock is
ticking
who do you prefer why you're black i
think i would take white
i think white i don't think white is
going to lose this game
so for example after a move like d4
let's just
put some moves on the board then i would
have played d4 just by the way but
you would not the thing i'm scared about
playing d4
is that if for some reason c and d are
exchanged
without any you know advantage to black
there's no rook c2 there's no knight
takes d4 hitting my b3 pawn
if i can just cleanly exchange them for
example something like rook ac1 dc3
bishop c3 happens
then you can start thinking you know
what
this bishops they're pretty good
and that's what i'm worried about i
think if i was black i would play d4 in
a very controlled scenario
and i'm not sure that i'm there yet
okay interesting uh but it's very
concrete right
so yes give me a move that you
think white should play did you like
sorry did you like rook ac1
or did you like this i'm not really too
sure because
this was the problem that i thought
white was having
that if you do take on d4 and this rook
does
land on c2 i mean
you could chase it
but it i mean practically speaking that
could be a draw
right away no i thought i thought rook
ac1 was was good enough was the more
yeah because for the moment you cannot
move your knight on e6 because it's him
yes
yes that is that is the awkwardness of
this whole line
uh knight d5 and this is where you're
kind of talking right if i just trade
the d-pawn and the c-pawn
then you start to like to favor the
bishops
yeah the a5 is always hanging so you
have to be careful on e6
is going to hang right so right yep yep
yep yep yep
so i i would take black but i wouldn't
hurry with the move d4 and i feel like
d4 d3 is how i i lose these games i put
my phone
doesn't belong and then it gets captured
uh your your asset turns
your key asset turns into a key
liability okay
intriguing so and i think you know i
think the bottom line in this position
actually boils down to white's knight
and f1
the whole position like if this knight
passive yeah could just pick itself up
and and let's say go
to d3 d3 would be awesome which takes
as we know four moves one two three
four yeah if it could just land on that
square
like just go yeah then white is starting
to
feel very good about the possibilities
like that's a
a great knight with squares it could go
to and swears it controls and
squeezes the system controlling but that
night
right now is a hyper passive and that's
black's hope that this this piece just
takes too long
rook c6 was played in the game yeah and
just getting out of this pin
makes a lot of sense to me right that's
absolutely
juan carlos he just played the move b4
so
whoa now now we have some fight
yeah i don't know from where it came i
don't know where it came from
that's uh that's that's a double-edged
move uh do you think is ideas to take
with the rook here guys
i'm a little bit confused uh what is
going on here there is a rook trade
that this is for this is fort um
seems very strong here excuse me rook b5
is a very strong move yeah
sorry i i i was kind of mesmerized here
somehow uh you could trade i i don't get
a chance to play bishop take c3
mistake we could have taken on e we
shouldn't apply rook b5
maybe we should have taken on e8 first
right well how does that go bishop a5
rook takes knight c5 rook takes the aid
and here you have to take on b7 you have
to take on b7 but i have rook c8 at the
end and i hold on to the pawn exactly
or rookie rook v8 maybe it was more
precise
there must be a way to hold on to this
pawn somehow yeah okay
but uh but it takes you don't have to
play bishop a5
now the problem is i yeah that's the
problem
is the desirable taking on c3 whoops or
rook takes e6 yeah and
taking advantage of the pin on the
seventh rank so
uh maybe i should just set up
well i don't like being in this pin i
must say but
i am set up to play bishop c5 on my next
turn
maybe because i play rook b5
immediately to just sidestep yes or
or rook to b1 might do the trick rook
eb1
because you can't take on c3 yeah same
variation right bishop a3
trait b7 you have this issue
okay but maybe in no i you're right i
still have this
issue i was about to say maybe in this
line i have something like knight d8 but
no it was rook b3
also okay uh continuing our just
our that's a big deal that he played
that move guys this position
seemed ultra quiet it didn't it looked
slightly dull if you will and he was
ready to play this move
almost at all cost b4 this
changes the equilibrium right oh it
blows it up yeah
john might have felt like okay he's not
doing much let me just trade off maybe
i'll get right
right or simplify then dude plays b4
and changes the whole pawn structure the
idea being to take and take with the
rook
like willingly shattering your pawns
isolating your pawn
but saying well but you've got an
isolated b-pawn
that's dynamic play this is i'm
i might have been a sleepy dragon in the
first part of the game
but now the teeth are out and i'm coming
to get you
this is big time this last move before
that shows that white
has every intention of trying to win
this game but let's just uh
put that in perspective because once
white did recap
or if he does recapture with the rook i
mean again this
pawn structure you know it is
you cannot rook takes the eight in this
position
and afternoon and bishop to diesel
nice little geometric trick right there
exactly
oh i wanted to play just defend my
be a be a hero but oh oh oh
oh so that makes it even more difficult
hmm
again i'm just finding myself in this
awkward
very very awkward uh five
might make more sense though all right
knight c5 defends b7 right that's and
also
knight d8 yeah that was what knight d8
was all about too
was to uh guard b7 but knight c5 is a
much more active move
i much prefer that i don't have to say
that if i take on e8 and i take on e8
and i just look at the position with
fresh eyes
i have the feeling that if i find some
move i have a pair of bishops
actually basically three might be that
some move right and
four and the knight on e8 is not
particularly good right now
i should have some way to remaneuver and
i like bishop e3
now big three is great it threatens
bishop d4 knight e3 is coming i mean now
it's gorgeous actually but
it makes sense right you have the
bishops yeah the position keeps opening
up
and this is one of the things that we
think about the pair of bishops
it's hard for amateurs to understand
that because at
i would say under the even 1800 level
knights are so tricky i just feel under
a certain level of chess
knights are better than bishops right
but when you give it
to a experienced grandmaster you know
that
close positions can open and opens the
positions very rarely close
he can make up new pawns right right
right so
you can see it that you exchange only a
couple of pawns you make a couple of
moves and the bishops suddenly spring
into action
right and along along with the pluses
that you already have by the way and
he's playing night to season 97
that's got to be plan b move it's not it
was not the
plan a turn that
knight c7 knight c7 it does i like it
i like knight c7 i'm telling you i
that that knight on e6 resolving that
tension between the bishop
on h3 the knight on e6 i like this move
to do that i think that that's a
priority by the way let me just uh
make sure that i went around the horn
completely
uh i did oh good i want to just once
again just
jump in the game of maxine because that
was
the game that i thought white had the
best
advantage and we saw this move knight d7
wow i mean visually optically you go
doesn't that just blunder a pawn but
black
i'm sure purposely made that pawn
sacrifice
like counting on rook f8 to win the pawn
back
but it won't win the pawn back i have at
least
what could he possibly be thinking of he
just donated this pawn
i think it was the lesser evil i think
he sees his
practical chances of surviving down a
pawn but with an active king and maybe
some active rogues that's higher
than the position that we had originally
and i don't think i can blame him
i mean so if black played a move like
castles and said
okay do your worst you think it
you think that that this disadvantage
that black has in this position is
is less it is more
it could be i think that's what he
evaluated us
okay because uh this is a whole pawn
this is a whole point but i thought i
would be castling also loses a pawn
right
castles might run into e5 right no
castle's bishop d6 loses a pawn i mean
there's many ways to win the pawn though
that's just one of them
yeah i'm i'm questioning also
forgive me but i'm also questioning the
move b5
isn't that just if i'm going to castle i
got to do it immediately
yep but if i cancel immediately and i go
e5
yeah knight h5 group d7
um something like and then you have b5
later maybe
i got that why didn't you play bishop h6
why did why didn't you
stabilize and then play for e6 bishop h6
here i'm not sure what e6 does
i can maybe you might have to take or
maybe even just if you do this i might
bring my rook to d7 yeah no no i don't
like giving v7 no no
take 26 you have to okay fair enough
that's why i was looking at this line
takes takes
so i mean i i would feel as black that
i'm
more in the game here than i am when i'm
upon down
but but maybe it was all part of this
whole b5 concept that carol
played for the game position if he has
done this i'm a little confused also
by the way i played rook to
d3 simply to defend the pawn on f3
no requirement to do that he could also
play rook c7
i don't think roxy seven is more natural
but i don't even get anything
like what if you're not playing for rook
f8 you're the d-file is not what you're
playing for
what else are you playing for you have
to be playing for our cafe
your king is going nowhere you're not
making any pawn breaks
you're not the only chance you have this
is the only hope he thought maybe i'd
get some counter play along the f5
and if he doesn't get that kind of play
what is he playing for
like and he doesn't look like he's going
to get it he just looks like a pawn down
this is like pretty bizarre
terrible because it just chooses this
it's also it's not like
you know being upon down and having an
active piece
like put this rook on e2 and say
okay this rook on e2 uh i
sacrificed a pawn for for great activity
something wonderful uh
where's the activity here i mean could i
point out
well yeah oh my goodness this is almost
not quite
uh there's a there's a simplifying line
with doubling rooks
right so that after you so that after
rook here
so i i could move the bishop but
but probably just take this this is the
argument i'm having if we go for this
position
this is a simplifying line then play
rogue d3 and bring the king up this
probably is not what
we want because this is too much play
yeah just as a pure rook ending
this is where i feel like black's best
chances might be
i would agree because the king is
actually pretty
good blockader after all but why can't
we be on e3 there for us to make this
line work
yeah i like the idea of keeping the
bishops on the board though maurice
i mean just to your point i i like what
you had right here
if you just go okay take your pawn but
guess what
yes now that's my
you know my turn so many choices but
rook c7 was played by maxime one of the
moves that we considered as quite strong
and
instantly the move rook hc8 we do have
to mention that alexenko is in some time
pressure not huge but
27 minutes for the remaining 29 moves uh
that's not comfortable
so he's played rook hc8 pretty much at
tempo i don't
have to take this rook on c8 because
you're not threatening anything
birdie one looks normal i think bringing
the king to e2 looks more normal to me
king d2
just start with that put the king where
it belongs yup
i would love to put it on e3 actually
but i'm going to have to face a check so
let's put it on e2 for now
solidify the central pawn structure and
this is just the pawn
it's just a win very good pawn
very good on closing in on one result
game like this yeah
yeah you've seen maxime not be great
technically in the end games
but so this is the kind of end games
he's supposed to win
yeah and what a chance if he wins this
game that's gonna be
real if he wins this game he gets nepo
tomorrow
with his blood boiling and his only
chance
is to defeat him destiny and that
changes the whole
tournament this is the whole thing wide
open this is the thing that
nepal wants to see the least for his
future
rival yeah you still have a chance and
with the rest day to go
yeah yeah i shut that down you don't
want you don't want your guys getting
confidence and stuff like that the more
i'm looking at this position
guys maurice i think the doubling of the
rooks was
enormously strong much stronger
than rooksy wanna rook to d3 because
if carol's idea is to trade
one rook you're not getting it you can't
take with the bishop
because of check but i thought we were
talking about rook have faded against
rook d'youville correct
correct and then after bishop here we
were looking at rook f3
rook here is like wait a minute
i got i got a big stick
i mean yeah i'm gonna double rooks like
if the bishop tries to move away
let's say you gain a temp i mean
actually you lose the sea pawn anyway
you
you lose the sleep on straight yeah
like what this is i don't understand why
double rooks was not played that just
looks
double rough it felt like you had
options after doubling rooks
the thing is the same game also looks so
winning i don't i'm not so sure about
the line that you guys are mentioning
like rook hd1
rook f8 bishop g3 rook takes
root c7 bishop g5 i understand white's
winning but now we're
we're choosing which one's the easiest
one and i go by four
i'm like is this really the easiest king
up obviously
uh yeah i would say it's uh
now i'm just actually am i going to mate
you
that's it if you don't made me i'm like
taking on g3 i'm taking on e4
so you do have to calculate that you're
mating me right and are you
okay let's see check
i don't i think at this point i should
go back
okay because if i go do i go if i go
forward what happens
i think it was gonna be a mate uh
i assumed there was going to be a mate
an erupt shack
no i don't see it crazy it might exist
but i don't see it
not immediately oh my gosh that would be
amazing
uh yeah no i bishop f4
rook takes king king here
i would have thought hard to believe
yeah yeah i would have thought that this
would be pretty
uh straightforward for white but okay if
it's difficult it's difficult
nothing else to say um
i'm wondering about c4 just
feels like i should have an 8. okay uh
like i was saying i i thought that the
the doubling of the rooks
uh was the easiest hold on let me
let me just see this again not
at all nobody does i mean what are you
kidding me nobody believes you right now
nobody believes it bet larson that was
i was hilarious when he said it too
because it was like
you know we were holding court we had a
really big crowd of people watching and
what he said it was like
everybody just lost it and started
laughing i thought that was damn good
nice bent um bishop before being
actually quite sophisticated it's the
only move because otherwise i kind of
resigned rook c6 yeah coming
and i just died so i have to give myself
e5
it's the it's the way that a lot of
these 2600 2700 players
slip away right they finally hold on
hold on rook d5 check
is it winning i just i think i see a win
rook d4 check
uh-huh where do you go now i i think i
have to go to f5
and you're doing this is ridiculous
really i know it but
you're barely alive but hey you know
where there's
yeah i could take a pawn but where this
whole well
i mean the king is actually pretty
active i'll play g5 i'll play h5 is this
losing probably but
yeah this is the easiest way to convert
i don't know i don't know
uh what we do have in the game and let
me just uh slip back and forth by the
way is we do have rook c8
and and maxine is just thinking
obviously
uh i do like your centralization of the
king
no question about it that that looks
really uh
the most normal i like the activation of
the rook as well somehow i like
uh bringing my rook to d1
uh let me jump back to a very very
crucial
game of the round and this is between
the players who are number two
and number three in our standings and we
did see
after king h1 queen b8
anish his play in the sicilian
is is really getting a lot of respect
he's really
learned the sicilians the ins and outs
very well and i like his play uh
fabi is trying to do something he's
played b4 b5
rook over
okay and counter spiel down the
c file takes takes knight d5
queen f8 queen fade is a very unusual
maneuver queen b8 queen f8
yeah it's not something you see often if
ever
yeah but he's just defending the dark
squares around as king
uh avoiding any kind of bishop h6 kind
of business and in the meantime
pawn on c2 uh pay attention and
we're up to date with the players
sorry i agree with what your earlier
evaluation of it was it seems very even
uh that white has a bunch of weaknesses
but on the other hand he has this nice
control over d5 black has that control
over the dark squares
yeah how to evaluate this well
i mean i have seen so many uh from the
old soviet days where
they would give up that bishop and they
would plonk their bishop on
f6 and say that knight on e5 is as good
as the bishop on e2
and very few players could ever prove
that
that wasn't the case so uh my first
impressions were still the same balanced
i don't see white as having anything
special but i do see
a weak pawn over here that white has to
deal with
does it make any sense a move like
knight
before it's like one of those moves that
if i can if i can do a lot of things
with the tempo
uh and hold you up but gosh what am i
doing after night before
i always feel that when your tempo
involves removing that powerful knight
from d5
yeah it's not it's not the cleanest
tempo
right okay just for the audience imagine
i'm going to do a number of things wrong
imagine that white gets to put his
bishop on a6 yay for what's at work
he's defended the pawn on c2ea
but then as alejandro is saying the
knight on d5 has
given up its dominant position on the d5
square
to protect a weak pawn on c2 and whereas
the follow-up
normally speaking bishop takes e5 is not
enough for advantage
i don't know guys looks very balanced a
quick check in
on alexander grishok yes i see what
grishik is doing
no i don't understand what white has so
i think advantage black but maybe
spanish black
yeah sure why not uh
because do you want to take this no
no okay so then you got to leave the
bishop on sea
for forever right you've just got to
say i mean i don't want to think right
now but okay
uh but actually if i do take right now
let's see and now i have to calculate no
then i'll take like this because
no but then i might allow b5 okay then
i'll take with the d1
and d5 d5 holy smokes
is that legal i have to calculate i hate
calculating
okay this is starting to get very v6
right right
this is starting to get really weird
take one second probably nothing right
here for white
i think only seven you take on c3 and
c5 might be worried yeah this is
yeah this doesn't work so you're gonna
have to move your rook right
so let's start with moving my rook uh
usually the row goes to b1
okay a b a b and now just because the
fact that this bishop
is alive it does help support the a2
squared now
um let's usually you play these
positions right you play these positions
and
you just leave a knight on c3 and black
can't ever use the a file for anything
and you concentrate on the king's side
okay
so let's say i go bishop um
f6 i don't know why but i kind of just
like
trying to induce the move knight e5
light but if i
take and go f5
take take an
f5 well
i guess you're playing into
what i want am i trying to achieve this
i don't know what i'm trying to achieve
but
on d5 i've got the open
file should be good for black
really it's funny though we have such a
different evaluation i'm so worried from
back here
i take on e6 i go d5
and i take a knight let's say i take on
e6
oh i'm hitting your my rooks on the
right side i cannot do this yeah maybe
nothing
actually works and black's doing great
that's possible i don't know uh this
bishop on f6 as a
mighty good defender in these positions
what about knight e4 instead of
taking on e6 i didn't really like taking
this knight
e4 after f5 okay i'm sorry
f5 knight e6 uh at knight f8 knight e6
uh knight e4 yeah
easy for you guys to say uh
i don't know uh rook a2
you will take on f6 and maybe
i'll give you the rank yeah if you want
if you feel good about that the thing
about this position is the a file is
deceptively
like it's not important it seems
important but you can't really do
anything with the black rooks
penetrating on the a file even when they
do penetrate and it's rare that they can
i remember a game that uh hikaru
nakamura absolutely destroyed
vishyanan on the black side thanks to
the queen a file queen e4
no no threats
i'm just trying to just bring my queen
over to g4
and so you guarding all that stuff
yeah guarding all the king side pawns
yeah no here i do have
i i i have dinged my
structure no question about it i was
trying to get my
rooks uh on the a5 before i get
my rooks to work though that's the only
thing but you go h5 and
hope i'm sorry h5 and hope
yeah i'm gonna take twice on e6 yeah
i don't know if it works but also i'll
start looking at it
yeah uh okay you can see i i
not easy for black jeez i'm i'm thinking
black is just a move or two away from
total domination and you guys think
white's in here with a shout knight h4
right h4 it's a weird position
it's very weird and they are going
into rook a b one as i suggested it
takes
eight takes that's the current position
uh on the board
we were mentioning bishop f6 there are
other ways of playing this position
for the moment i would say f5 is a bit
of a threat
uh so probably you want to recover from
that yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's the main idea right yeah is to play
f5 you've got these double pawns
and he's taken on d3 interestingly whoa
okay that was definitely not a move i
expected
i love this tension of this bishop on d3
i guess ash's idea guys we should jump
to the games
with nepo because there's been a big
development there in terms of this
beautiful night maneuver night back to
c7 that's the
dancing of that night i mean just
extraordinary you talk about
the other side is two bishops but
how are you going to anchor your night
and this move knight to d6
c3 is hanging the knight is getting
activity
fascinating position by nepo and clearly
a big moment as he's down upon at the
moment
rook to b3
rook to b three it's funny did we have
something like this
in our analysis of how we transposed to
a position that we might have gotten
through a different move order rook to
b3 uh
help me out here we never got the
knights of d6 though
why didn't he recapture the pawn at once
um we are threatening
bishop takes d2 and rook c2 perhaps it
doesn't make a difference but
i i don't see an immediate refutation to
this move
i don't think they're bishop d7 i mean
okay
i mean there's some traits but no you
don't
okay he didn't do that he played big
moments
another big that's really weird
a win by the way may end the tournament
yeah
i i agree with that i mean i think a win
for nepo is
that's no that's that that that that's
crazy mr c3 looks
very equal and it and very dry should
that
if he wanted to make a draw he could
have played that way
but maybe but but better maybe he's got
knight d6 yes what do you play
well we started running through three
the defense d4
is definitely with the idea of rook c2
yeah so just
this is for for our audience you should
take on d2 right away probably yeah no i
don't think it matters the same
either way you get your knight to c4 and
you win
that's a piece okay well then d4
you don't want to see d4 takes c3
showing up on your doorstep if you're
white
so so then this is fine too maybe
nepo is going to have to well rook b2
knight c4 and i was thinking
here if anybody's better i would prefer
to be
white because i don't think this guy is
as dangerous as this guy i think
this outside past pawn is more dangerous
but you don't have to take on c3 you can
play knight
here and take on d2 and then i don't
think you have anything whatsoever to
worry about
but you're right what do you mean
anything listen like how do you survive
as white
what really after rugby to knight c4 how
do you start surviving this position
rook a2 you have to play right no no but
why do i have to hurry what's your next
move
i don't know i mean do i need a neck
okay my next move might be bishop to g5
i don't know uh but you're going to give
up c3
oh it's true i would give up c3 in that
case yes
well bishop e1 could be well because we
want to do there should be one
d4 you're almost in i just want
[Music]
but if this is true if if you guys are
getting the the feeling that nepo really
is pushing
i feel something then knight d6 is a
great move
i just thought boy is pushing bishop
season i think he can lose this game and
i think
i think he's pushing knight d6 came as a
surprise
now who's now stopped to really look
deeply at this position and realize that
his demonstration with b4 has
not worked out after some pretty deft
defense
i would like to point out deft i meant
skillful
listen that night on that night on f1
remember when we said man time ago
actually this knight on f1
and put it on d3 that's what we want
right just
move it to an but we knew it was
impossible to get the knight
to d well not impossible but it would
take forever to get it to d3
because this is the worst square
relative to a knight
that's close it takes the most moves to
get from
the square it's on to a square two
squares diagonally
away it takes four moves could you go
back a moment please before the move
knight to c7
look at the night just before knight c7
was played
so forward now a little bit yes okay now
take just before now take a look at the
knight on
e6 this knight on e6 might be dreaming
of c4 the same relationship two squares
away
how do i ever get to that square fast
forward
knight to c7 thanks for the trade
one step closer you can have the pawn
bang
i just found a c4 square and there you
go rook b2 we said
was a possible allowing knight so the
knight actually did what the
white knight could only dream of could
somebody force me to d3 please
like just make it happen the way it
unfolded in this game and it's just
miraculous of the night on e6 managed to
do
that dance and get to the c4 square and
just have
a beautiful square very dynamic indeed
for black
and i think nepo is thinking if i win
this game
wow well that would be what it is what
it would be
yeah it's it's all but you know book me
book me my seat at the uh world
championship
in dubai by the way after rook c8
mvl is really really thinking could he
be
could he be thinking about this move um
taking on c8 and king
uh d2 to e2 we all
oh hold on king to d2 immediately
getting it
yeah immediately immediately
is what we have been thinking
centralized the king
just make sure that your pawn on f3
is well protected and white's for choice
but
could i mean
it looks like a very strange way of of
play
could he be thinking about this that
makes no sense right i mean
a moment ago we had the rook here and
the rook here
and we were saying that's not even the
easiest win for white
um no i we don't understand why
uh nbl is taking so long over the move
king
to david ii fabi fabi's position
no change after queen f8 and finally
dingler no and by the way a few moves
have been played
those little little moves uh h5
uh just kind of
shutting down a few things stopping i
don't know
g6 bishop g7 uh
making sure that you'll always be able
to get to play h5
f5 now that the pawn is on h5 rook a3
queen c2
and we've caught up to the play here
this fobby position
is concerning as well because obviously
these two players draw and nepo wins
the map says wow the map says
so what is fabi supposed to do here
i'm assuming it's white who's trying to
win but black might
start saying you know three results if
you don't
if you keep trying to win somebody's
gonna have weaknesses and
c3 has been played
i'll tell you what favi needs to do he
needs to move he has 15 minutes
for 29 moves this is
this is no no 29 19 moves critical
situation for him he better not collapse
here
what happens if doubling rooks though i
mean it looks like
i mean doubling rooks right now bishop
takes d5
this is a normal uh sicilian counter
play on the half open c file right
do i have time to take on e5 and say
that i get my pawn to d6 if you take on
d5
is that something what like this
uh alejandro
[Music]
and i don't know this looks equal
it does it just does
it looks rook c8 played when ricci won
instant reply
defending the c3 pawn saying all right
i'll play that out
and you know like these were those
endings uh from the soviet championships
that i saw so many times they would take
on d5 and
they would just they'd just take on d5
and
i mean honestly you can even give up the
pawn right now right
i'm sorry what if you even if you give
up the pawn for free like taking on the
fight and yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying worse at all
you're not lower i mean i'm sure you're
equal i remember
it was a game that mvl played where he
just like
it was a feshnikov where the guys got a
knight a pawn on d5
and he just gave up this d6 pawn
and he got this dark square bishop it
was from a grand chest or event
he won it with the black side upon down
and this i don't think is any problems
for
anish after takes on d5 i
and i just throw up this move rook
i think even rookier is something
very very uh similar um again
if it's black to move black plays bishop
f6 i prefer
black but if you do end up in a
in a situation like for example here
um i don't think that this is a way
anything anything these the the ponds
are so beautifully blockaded who gets
rid of the bishop on d6 like which
can't tell me the piece that's going to
attack that bishop exactly
so on ish gary looking very
comfortable let's just leave it at that
first comfortable
but think about anish's position he's
walking around the playing hall
and he sees that one how he doesn't have
that great of a position anymore
right i mean you see 96 visually and you
look at it for two seconds and you
realize
well that's not so fun for white
if he draws he's a full point behind
nepo
with the worst typewriter
in that case it's over he he's got a
he's but you know what the reality is
you can't assume that wang is going to
lose
and you can't start doing crazy stuff
and lose the game
right so what you have to do is keep
playing the position
move by move by move keep playing the
position
and i hope it trends yeah some the guy
does something spooky
crazy nutty whatever
yeah because if you start thinking oh my
goodness let me get desperate especially
how do you get desperate in a position
like this i don't know like what do you
do how do you make it like
whoa let's get let's play h5 like
well i you mean if i if you were gonna
play for a win as black
yeah yeah i would i would i would start
looking at ideas of knight g6 bishop
h4 idea behind knight g6 is you want to
preserve some pieces you don't want to
see everything traded off
rook c5 rook a5 ideas
different things would come to mind i i
do see i do think
it's a perfectly good move but i will
say about that move
i don't know what exactly bishop h4
seems to allow something like queen e3
well the idea more or less is
i want to just keep a lot of pieces on
the board and
when when i make the decision to play
bishop takes d5
i'm trying to make it under the best
set of circumstances for black people so
you're actually
proving my point make some slow
right the position see what happens
you don't you can't be desperate here
you also don't want to just trade pieces
off and make a draw
but that's what i'm saying i think one
thing you don't do i think in a normal
game you just take on d5 here
not exactly right if it was candidates
is the way it is right now
we put more attention to nitrogen if a
niche we're playing
me or you one of us
as anybody rated sub 2700 he plays
bishop takes d5
no i mean why does he need to
he's not worse why would he he could
play if if he needed to just
make a draw with black he could take on
d5 yeah
but why does he need to i mean in a the
normal game
where you're playing in this an elite
tournament with
fellow 2790s and you say yeah it's okay
for a draw with black but if
if you have this position and you just
want to play you don't need to play
any trades and if you're in and you and
by the way
if you're magnus carlsen do you just
play bishop d5 and just and uh
make a quick draw in a normal position i
think it really depends upon the
tournament circumstance i mean if it's
earlier in the tournament
if it's very early in the tournament i
think you just like to play and check
your form
am i in a good form uh and yeah you just
play the position
um bishop it's it's weird i don't even
know why i'm
starting to think about you know
bishop to d8 the the reason i'm thinking
in this way
is if i'm going to take on a3 i'd like
to take with the queen
that was like the queen on f8
is doing not so much on f8 but i don't
know
it's i guess soft play this he has no
big edge
he just has to keep making find a way to
keep making moves
bobby has 16 minutes for how many moves
that's the thing that starts to get
interesting for me as a competitor
when i see my opponent spending a lot of
time and not
necessarily coming up with a lot of
really great solutions
yeah then i start thinking okay how do i
keep
play in the position on the board
and let him help you yeah let him
help you don't think you can make
something happen
where there's nothing make him help you
play some interesting moves
slight if it can if you can make a
double-edged move that's equal
play that move instead of the boring
move that's equal
right i always like the uh comment from
uh walter sean brown
a six-time u.s champion who says you're
sir sometimes you know you just gotta
you you you gotta give the guy enough
rope to
hang himself he can't just take off all
the pieces
you gotta give the guy enough rope to
hang that's right
that's right that's how chess works
that's how it just works sometimes
you cannot prove that you're better and
start i want to win
ergo let me force moves home that's not
how chess works
you've got to be a competitor and play
the circumstances
and let the other player
go by himself
do some self self-inflicted pain and
that's i think what anish is doing right
now he's looking for ways to just keep
the game going
without further trades he probably is
inspected
bishop to d8 he's probably looked at
knight g6 he wants to keep pieces on the
board
i would just uh jump into uh
mvl's game again from a competitive
point of view
mvl wins this game
puts himself maybe in destiny's chair as
he will have
nepo uh recall reminding everybody that
mvl was the only player to inflict a
loss upon a nepo
so far in this tournament we haven't
talked about
mvl's tie breaks if mvl could put
together a win streak wouldn't
that just be amazing i mean we'd be so
shocked
you know considering what's happened to
him in the second half of the tournament
that's off to him but he's a bit far
away right now yeah it depends on this
one
game honestly we were just calling it a
draw i think
straight out of the opening right what
could be more drawers than that
opening that they played but
let's take a look at their lifetime
score
one win for nepomniacci i don't remember
it actually six losses
and whoo cross that is a bat
i did not know he's sick
the worst guy he could possibly play
this guy
owned him in classical chat i mean i
remember the most
important i think mvl victory over nepo
was that sink field cup
for the money that's right big time
that's a
big time of reason that's a great stat
by the way this that is slightly better
than we will say
and a lot better yeah boy i fix it
with when i think of mvl by the way with
six wins i'm saying
from nepal's point of view if i didn't
have to deal with that mdl guy
i'd be number two in the world that's
guy that guy's cost me 50 rating points
look this is a that's a big result six
to one
and let me tell you when you are in the
candidates
you've got to put up a number in the
last four tournaments
since this candidate has returned to the
tournament format it's four minutes this
is the score
that won each of these event we see the
events we see magnus crossing eight and
a half which one down
on eight and a half i thought sergey had
gotten nine actually in his campaign but
apparently it is eight and a half
and then fabi got nine in 2018 there's
one guy right now who's
who can look at that number and say i
can score eight and a half
and his name is nepo he's sitting on
seven
right now three draws gets him to the
magic
number and possibly the biggest
payday well it would be the biggest it
would be
his life and history forever
will be written your name you were one
of the challengers to the world
championship
title so everything on the line that's a
number eight and a half
if we look at the score of the players
right now getting to eight and a half
we assume that's the number who can get
to eight and a half
realistically and how would they do it
we did speak about nepo
on seven but if we can take a look at
the scores we see
anish at six and a half eight and a half
gets him
to with he can get there with a win in
two draws right
you can happen with nepo on eight and a
half as well because
he'll be devastated by the tie breaks
that happened who did it happen
magnus carlsen 2013.
yeah when he when he it was two players
on eight and kramnik
both was famously lost in the last round
of in 2013 by the
tie breaks favored magnus bobby to get
to eight and a half
two wins and a draw he better win now
i mean that's uh that's a big deal he's
not getting to his nine that he got
to become the candidate last time and
maxine vashila grav well
eight and a half from five and a half we
know how to get there
[Laughter]
i know the answer how he could do it and
grishtrek by the way
also has the same challenge ahead
of being able to try to jump win three
in a row win three
so yeah well maxine
i mean uh we don't know absolutely that
eight and a half is necessary
but if he could put together back to
back when starting today
and winning on monday
because tomorrow will be a free day
his confidence will be through the roof
and
every all the other competitors would be
very grateful
and by the way the players after bishop
d7
i must say that nepo
i am now warming up to the idea that
nepo
is in fact the one who's pushing because
uh the bishop on d7 funnily enough
is not really participating and then
this knight on f1 has not moved
since it landed on f1 essentially so
yeah oops something went wrong with my
board i apologize let me just
turn off that engine i didn't mean to do
that
um back to fabi and anish for a moment
this this game is getting even more
critical that it
that it has a decisive result guys
from what we're seeing and you know the
last two moves by fabi what i find
fascinating is how he played
these two passive moves who would have
suspected white is sitting in this
position
saying i got more space i have more
active pieces
theoretically speaking and
i have to play c3
and rook c1 i think he just didn't find
the plan and that's right thing about
the position right you have this
beautiful knight on d5 but the fight is
covering
that's about it right the queen on f8 is
covering the entire king side
very famously in the sicilian once the
pawn on e5 is traded for the pawn on the
f-file and the knight
lands on that e5 square it really kills
the play and without any play on the
queen side because your pawn structure
is also worse there
your bishop on e2 being okay but without
any targets
he i think he's not worse but he didn't
find a plan
that was active and he said well i gotta
defend my pawn what to do
but i'm sure that was not the way that
he wanted to play that position
no i absolutely agree with that i mean
you sit in this position
and you've played a lot of attacking
moves like you said he's played oops
excuse me that
came out wrong he has played the move f2
f4 he's brought his queen over to the
queen to d3 to g3 eyeballing
opportunities i don't know
whether they be with bishop g4 bishop h5
he's been
in aggressive mode right and suddenly
these last two moves is kind of an
indication well all your aggression
has been well met and uh black is just
simply fine by the way we do have on the
on the board the move knight g6
uh perfectly acceptable as you said uh
alejandro knight g6 and
very quickly bishop d2 once again
so knight g6 i like for both players
honestly because you play the game alive
right keeps the game alive
it hurts their chances if this game
starts spitting out
petering out to a draw yes and
let's just play a few moves for black
here help me out uh
uh bishop h4 uh the reason i like this
is not just because i want to take your
queen i do want to take your queen
but i also want to get my bishop out of
this uh attack and i do want to take the
d5
knight and i do want to put my bishop
back on f6 so
in other words if i could induce queen
f3 and that's probably a very very bad
idea don't get me wrong
uh it means that there's no more rook f
uh
rook takes f6 sacrifices that i have to
deal with
uh what do you think of bishop h4
yeah and as i'm gonna suggest rook to c5
blocking the pawn blocking the attack on
the pawn
and just prepping bishop takes d5
so that e4 takes d5 will not be the
tempo
and preparing rookie 8 i don't know
bishop can drop back to f6 i'm looking
at this guys
and i'm thinking fabi's slipping i like
i like black yeah it's like
dream sicilian right right your king is
ultra safe look at look at black's king
you know
in a sicilian think of all those
marvelous victories by tal and other
great players
you're not attacking black's king
black's king is ultra safe
oh do you guys remember this incredible
game between
shaq mami daroff and boris gelfand
boris gelfan like sacrificed a rook for
like four pawns
yeah of course but he had two bishops in
front of his king
it was like the safest king i've ever
seen in my life
i mean it was like a bug house king and
it was like wasn't that a candidate as
well
i wanted to say wasn't it the candidate
that was candidates in kazan 2011
right right and i was thinking that that
belonged in the sicilian hall of fame
that game this game is like one of those
games where you know
black's showing why the sicilian is such
a dangerous
defense to e4 players
and we have not seen the pardon me we
have not seen the move rook c5 no on the
board yasser on the board
c5 already played yeah and again i'm
just
slippage right this there was a rook on
d1 the
bishops are kind of passive so what do
we do here as
white we need to come up with some sort
of plan i hate your rook on c4
if i would like to expel it maybe c4 if
i can get away with it
precisely that you you you said the
magic there
uh you that rook on c5 also i
didn't really like to see that maybe
tickle me over here
but i did like the move c4 because
you're absolutely
right i'd like to expel it but what if
this knight comes back
and says question because bishop b4 does
knight take c forward
probably not right probably not
i assume queen d4 should win some
material
queen d4 yeah so
that might be the answer uh
and if we take this guy
man if man if you have to take like this
or you've been running pressing it
true that well we've got more on the
board you okay
channeling my boy yeah you've been
working
how long have you actually worked with
uh you've known fabi from for for many
years but you certainly were
uh helping him on his candidates right
this was our big project and um
candidates and of course the world
championship match we worked on and off
before that like looking at some chess
but nothing
official but the world championship
match was maybe
three or four months of actual
preparation
so that was that was pretty brutal yeah
i can imagine
when you think okay you're working with
a uh
your fighter your fighter is uh fabi and
it's like boxing you're working with
your
fighter and you you say to yourself my
fighter has these strengths this is fabi
is like this great calculator
he he's this he's this he's this he does
all of these things really well
when you when you were working with
pappy
where did you say gosh darn it fappy
you've got a weakness
it's a time trouble what's fabi's
weaknesses that he needs to improve
i actually do know the answer but i
can't say it on there okay
then we'll leave it okay all right
all right very good uh uh by the way uh
clock times 16 minutes
to 24 minutes anything else happening in
the other games guys
and let's take a look at the nepo game
see if that has any changes
uh this is a crucial game with
uh the leader but it does seem like wang
hao found a way to neutralize
black's slight initiative this really
does smell like a draw
it definitely yeah absolutely this one
is well
i i think it was actually right here i'm
not saying anything other than to say
that this bishop on d7
doesn't feel very impactful to my eyes
and
maybe i would want to in fact
retain the the pair of minor pieces not
to
capture because i think after knight
takes d7
that was a a bit of a relief for
wang hao to get rid of his worship c5
f4 maybe
rook c5 bishop f4 okay let's let me put
my rook on c4 why am i putting my
my uh rook well maybe anyway bishop
bishop f4 bishop to d4 let me
uh introduce my bamboo stick
rook rooksy to check on tap
i'm just saying keeping some pieces on
the board might have been a better
chance
uh by the way wang how if i'm reading
that right yeah but don't worry
they're very close 46. only two moves
away
yeah yeah okay to the time control so
it's not outstanding but by the way
that's one of
in my opinion yan's extraordinary's
abilities is his ability to really out
tempo as in time
his opponent he's usually the one uh
with plenty of time on his clock and his
opponent is under
uh time travel one's looking very but
okay he did not do that
he did not do that he did take on d7
and reach this position and
well we we we've been crying for this
knight to move but
knight here d4 is a problem that's kind
of annoying this move
a5 i know isn't it
a well but how i don't know how big a
thread is this pawn yeah king f2 is
probably what's wrong with king f2
this seems so natural oh excuse me no
king f2 looks
very very six might bring my king over
yeah this is i think that this would
probably just be a drawn
yeah yeah um
i think f6 rookie seven what a weird
move
what rook e7 i loved the rook
on d7 being behind the funny thing is
that if i was white in this position i'd
probably consider the move rook d7
right i would play it never mind
consider it
i mean okay what
question what huh so if i go wrong okay
six
and i hit your pawn so he said it's a
he's got a very specific idea he's got
rookie five in mind
thank you for that marie i don't know if
it's
no i think that is exactly his idea
right
yeah so he's either going to get after
five or bring his work
back to e2 and do it this way
gotcha that makes a lot of sense
actually
okay because it is funny you're
absolutely right that
you know if my rook was on e7 i would be
thinking about wanting to play rook to
d7
it's quite a quite a funny uh
move i i didn't guess that one that is
for sure rookie seven let me again just
a quick check on fabi after c4
um some time has been ticking
after the move h7h6 oh wow greece
you're you're channeling anish you're
saying you know those little
little moves keep it keeping all of the
play have
have a little rope by the way uh no more
back rank mates for you and deal with
bishop to g5
yes is it is it really what i want to do
bishop g5
maybe well you you stopping bishop b4
because bishop g5 would yeah and no but
absolutely you want to play bishop g5
you're going to try the dark square
bishops you want to take on d5 establish
a knight on e5 and say
hey that's a knight on e5 against the
bishop on e2 right
you're right you actually you actually
forced the next mover or you actually
telegraphed a threat because i don't
want you to know i want to play bishop
g5 right you know
because then because then you know you
know you need to stop it
you want to make moves that the person
doesn't suspect your intentions but at
this level of course everybody's looking
and seeing everything on face value at
the board
but still eight six all the
all the earmarks of a quiet move that
has some poison
that does some nice things that doesn't
clarify anything and tells you
you probably have to move your queen
right now
where to right where are you going to
put it
oh yeah you're going to go to d3 and
allow 95.
b3 is probably the square but it might
allow a tempo and a b line somewhere
just keep wondering what to do keep
thinking
with 13 minutes on your clock and a long
way to go to time control
yeah that's the most important part
right we're nowhere near time control
and
no white still has all this
uncomfortable decisions yes bishop g5 is
a threat and i need to take care of it
but where's the queen go it's not like
it has one square obviously better than
the others it would be nice if you had
only one square
right as opposed to yeah where should i
go this could it be that one could it be
that one
and the fact that you actually have to
move it when you play queen b3 it's not
like you go to b3 and say
yeah i'm going to b3 because yeah baby
i'm i got it this threat b7 is hanging
tactics everywhere no you're just trying
to find the best safe square for your
queen
to go hide so it doesn't get bothered
anymore
so initiative a niche all the way
this is getting scary for fabi it's not
scary
it's the wrong word but a little bit
concerning concerning for sure
that's a good one it's definitely yeah i
feel
uh a you know higher level of concern
and you're making a very important point
too alejandro for
those players um uh
new to the game this idea of getting a
situation
where it's a what we would call good
night you put a good
you we're just going to make a bad move
for a moment this good night on
e5 versus a bad bishop on e2 the bad
bishop
is a bishop that is restricted by its
own pawns it's restricted and it's
defending its own
pawns whereas this knight on e5 can
easily be leveraged to other types of
play
including for example g5 g4
it's exactly what i like to call a thor
you know with a hammer um so yes there
are dangers for white what you just
pointed out
it may be that black plays the move
anyway
right so fabian the pawn on
f's important g5 is certainly not what
you want
you'd rather have well i say certainly
it has its advantages but
it's preferable we would estimate that
it's that the trade of dark squared
bishops
without compromising the pawn structure
in any way by putting this
in g5 preferable yeah be preferable but
hey you got to win the game so maybe
you've got to give to get
and so you might do it anyway because
you always have f6 although that's going
to weaken some light squares and the
bishop might feel like it has some life
but if you get your knight to e5 very
quickly
right and then later bring the queen to
guard you might just do it
anyway and say hey i got you on lockdown
now are you just going to be defending
this for the rest of your life yeah what
is white's plan
right i'm going to put a queen on e7
defend both a7
the 7th and g5 putting the knight on e5
and you know what i'm going to start
eyeing
g6 king g7 oh yeah
oh yeah maybe not not such a bad idea to
give myself the double pawns
check it out i got another idea so
that's the problem for fabi
that doesn't just look like a passing
threat it looks like it's coming yeah
that's going to be on the board at some
point and i'm going to have to trade off
my darts where bishop be left with
rancid pieces this bishop on e2 versus
that knight
i can't let this continue he has played
queen to b3
ah and we hold on i've got a
big alert alert what is going
on we're being told that nepo is winning
i do not know why
but rook e7 is the move that kind of
confused us
jack and d4 and nebula
no no that's not waiting really wow
we
fake information i mean he might be
better he might be pushing
but he's not winning netflix
everybody guys
is there something we're missing here
that uh
but but this does look really bad for
yeah
it does look really bad actually this
one
wait wait a minute why is it really bad
just
that i don't know oh g4
my intended g4 will get crushed by
knight h4 excuse me
okay this knight on f1 we talked about
it like
hold on we don't like bad pieces and
that knight on f1
has been discussed again and again we
said we wanted to somehow get it to d3
it has not moved since the fantasy of
trying to get this knight
in the game i would have it almost
anywhere else
right about now what the heck is it
doing on f1 playing defense and knight
headed to f5
rook will be behind that pawn and oh
man black is starting to you know maybe
maybe our producer tom i i really
maybe maybe tom knows more than what we
do exactly yeah but maybe
maybe maybe you actually have to give up
this pawn right like
on a fi on the a file which is extremely
sad just to activate the knight
that would be very very very sad okay so
d4 maybe i have to take a different
approach and say yeah you know that's
also fun
exactly that was i thought you were
suggesting i thought you had to go rook
d7
because i don't want my rook on d1 i i
like that i was trying to get my knight
i know but i like my rook on this sound
i just don't know where you want how i
moved it from
guys wang has three minutes and 33
seconds it doesn't matter he may move
40.
did he make before he already yeah he
made from 40. oh he did so his king g1
move was moved 40 uh yeah knight f5 a5
knight f sorry uh i'm sorry uh
we're we're currently here after d4 do
you did you
like a5 or rook d7 rook d7 i think it's
the only one okay knight of five yeah
and i think you have to give up the
spawn a5 and just force force the rook
to take it so i can get my knight out of
though
i i just don't see another way to hold
this position would you rather have your
rook on d1 or your rook on d7 you just
i'd rather have your work on d7
i'm i'm beginning to feel how really
unpleasant the position is uh alejandro
this is
this is really getting unpleasant
here i'll go kingy too and i'll hope to
survive but do i survive every time
probably not
i'm not sure either yeah no
like i wouldn't guarantee blacks winning
but i wouldn't want to be
what happened here whose move is it is
it it's
it's it's white one turn white g4
g4 and
oh gosh darn it i i was
always thinking that knight h4 and
knight f3
was on tap but no once you play rook
takes d4
it's not a problem so i did it in the
wrong way
hold on so maybe after
knight d2 maybe here
i just have to start yeah no reason to
bring the king into the game with a
check
right that's where is this night going i
you know it was funny i was thinking
that the king was going to
be a detriment on e2 that was why i drew
it
uh desperate to get in the game no but
here i'll go 94 and i'll
finally prove that my knight is not so
bad
yay the knight is finally happy
so the issue here is it's and he has
played rook back to d7
yeah but what else could he do the rook
belongs to d7 behind the
spawn of course it does oh
terrible knight at five were forced by
nipple thanks absolutely by the way
to just give me all these free moves and
by the way you're gonna have to throw in
a pawn in the collection
you know is this like you know the white
has no useful moves right
you can't move the king you can't move
their pawns
yes so that is jus so yeah
process of elimination right yeah
well there is rook d5
but that's just inviting no but rook d5
loses a piece to rook c1
begging to die which yeah loses a
piece to rookie yeah that's coming
that that is definitely a a winning
alert oh dear oh dear
um okay uh knight
f5 okay so we're back to it does it lose
a piece does it is there king g2
you're right king actually holds the
piece because rook takes f1 rook takes
f5 but
do you really want to flirt with i don't
want to play it i was just you know we
they don't want to give uh propaganda to
the
to the audience so just making sure true
i
don't want to do it at all but because
it looks
horrible but just it just
it's already horrible yeah e7 rook back
to d7
sometimes the principles hold right
rooks and long behind past pawn
sometimes they hold what were you
thinking trying to bring your rook back
when your pick was ideally placed on d7
why could i have had two free moves
right okay so now we get to
a situation where we blundered upon we
we coughed up upon but we are
eyeballing knight e4 and knight g5 and
saying
i'm an idiot i apologize but i'm still
making a draw if i can play knight d4 to
g5
you know what's terribly useful it's a
d-pawn the board has shrunk
so the d-pawn doesn't stretch
the defenses you know like the way i did
that
deeper on defenses oh you guys anyway
that's so good
[Laughter]
okay but go on you like the d-pawn you
like the extra fun i like extra pawns
no i'm not saying no what i'm saying is
that for white
the board is smaller it's all on king
side center
yes exactly it's only that five files
wide
you want to have a smaller board so your
king doesn't have to think
man i gotta go catch that darn b pawn
or even worse an a pawn that's extra no
it's the d-pawn
that's closer to the white king so that
we can see when your knight
hopped to d2 and it's got its own ideas
the king can say king of two king e2 i'm
in
like i'm close right so that's a very
important point
in this position that it's the d-pawn
that white is fighting not
any fight as it moves one over one over
one over it would be
more difficult uh to defend so i think
white's defensive chances are definitely
there knight d2
and the other thing is lifting
blockaders
is a really hard thing i mean you
blockaded blockaded pawns
it takes it takes some specific uh
circumstances to be able to get rid of
things that are in your way
right so at night for example let's say
the knight is just sitting on d2
and doesn't move and the king comes over
to e2 as we saw in that position
you're gonna say well you know this this
knight the only way for me to get rid of
it is to attack it with the other knight
but i can't do that unless it's pinned
otherwise it's just going to get taken
so how do i lift it
right and so white could even put up a
defense where he's dreaming of putting
the knight on
the king on on e2 of the right
circumstances and it's not so easy
to even lift the block hating forces
it's just like it's just even if it just
sits passively you got to figure
how do i get at this if the king goes to
d3
and avoids the pin then you
what do you do to get rid of this knight
right it's just
blockade blockading pieces are
really require specific circumstances
like like a different color piece
a different type of piece excuse me if
you had a dark squared bishop you could
attack the knight
that's different right without it being
able to be captured
then you have something but then it may
blockade on a light square
and then you can't lift that piece so
the circumstances are not easy right now
for black
to make that extra pawn work even after
it happens at the moment he's not up
on because white is not moving
okay well we'll leave this uh for a
moment as
we do believe that dion is definitely
the one
pressing let's go to the game of mbl
because this is a game
that we thought that
white was in some kind of a easy cruise
control
and was bringing home the point is that
still true guys
looks like i wish i had a i wish i had a
rook on the board but
well it's funny you should say that
because it'd be like the very last one
was it necessary uh d5 and then you do
it oh well that would be over
no no no that's that's what i but how do
you
how do you win this with white that's a
good question what is my winning plan
here
that's that's what i'm saying isn't it
you're gonna bring your king to g4
yeah but i'll play h5 h5 is gonna happen
that's the problem the h5 move
after h5 how does white win
okay so let's say i go king c2
so the idea is i'm going to play b3
right
i am going to play you have to yes but
you're not going to be able to take it
you'll you'll go a3 which of course you
will do and you're happy
so let me just play some uh
moves so that everybody can understand
what i'm going to do
which is i'm going to
eventually get all the way
here right okay you've kept
your bishop nicely defending this pawn
and you've stopped my king from
creepy crawling in now you see why i put
my pawn on b2
so that it would it put my pawn on b3
so that it was never under threat so
intention is clear bishop h4 bishop g5
king h4 and an f5
is that so clear well that's the
potential
king h4 and f5 f5 oh you want to take
you want to trade everything off and
get left with the h-pawn yeah but i'm
going to go pick up that a2
and i'm going to start thinking of a
you're not gonna be able to give up your
dark squared bishop for my h-phone i'm
afraid
i'm not gonna let you uh sacrifice a
piece are you sure about that
i'm gonna gladly i'm gonna let you get
what i think is more than
okay all right bishop f2 what would you
like to play as black
i don't have a choice let's go like
bishop d6 or something
bishop d6 okay that actually
forces me to play bishop to three
and three and five i do kind of assume
that king f7 f5 is not something i wanna
ever allow so let's just move the bishop
again
bishop e7 okay so now i'm getting my
position right so now you're gonna get
your position so i go bishop b
d6 i go bishop f8
and i keep passing bishop d6
i pass bishop to f8
now here we stop for a second let me
threaten king to g5
that's maybe very important
you don't have a good move here kings
yeah
bishop h6 i do not like because f5 hits
the bishop at the end
and that's the tempo
yeah i mean it's going to be a tempo
later anyway this
we can't be nuanced now i mean we just
got yeah
no but this is the right one because
bishop fake for example
yeah i don't go ef5 i go king g5 and i
think that's an easy one
i picked that up your king never ever
gets in i distract your bishop with the
h pawn and your structure collapses
that's a problem okay you're warming to
the task
you're beginning to feel that uh there's
a
the defense is getting stretched with
this bishop to d8
yeah no i the more i see it the more i
agree with you
you know what yeah that means that h5
was a blunder
but i can force h5 wow i could just put
my king on g4 and i'm gonna go f5
uh so uh let's do it all again
the similar variation so we want to
provoke the move a3
and we go all the way here
and this is what alejandro's saying
marie says that once he puts this king
on g4
you're more or less obliged right
to play well i mean i was just going to
go five immediately i don't see why
oh i was yeah i was trying to put my
bishop on g3 but okay you want to go f5
but i think bishop f2 bishop g3 might be
the more clinical approach
just my thing was to try to get the king
in
and and uh get to a2 yeah but
i go [ __ ] with g three and play bishop
g3 bishop g3
is uh okay so now h5 is force for real
yeah
yeah we we've just transposed to our
okay so let's get to that
cooking let's get let's get back to that
position the bishop is not going to be
on age six then
we said it was a mistake so
did you put your bishop on now you you
guys have
actually been very very kind and polite
you've kind of gone
along with the blueprint you know oh i
don't need to get my pawn to h3 in this
case i can just go
here right away but i think it's good
technique right but upon h3
yeah it's gonna be attacked right but
here's the problem now i have
bishop to d6
but this is actually one of the things i
was going to ask you guys is
even if i got this position
just give up e4 yeah yeah
uh i'm not or no
i tell you what let me even play it
gross
in a in a really gross manner but here
we have to count right bishop g3
bishop to g3 let's count
take
yeah yeah that's easy so
it might be that uh i'm just winning
flat out winning a bishop
ending uh and i'm sure no no no no
hold on king h5 fe4 right yeah
what's your move king g66 king g6
so you have no threats i do
my threat is to push my h-bond up the
board but i have bishop e7 here
bishop e7 ooh
oh man that's uh that that that clears
some cobwebs
okay that means i should start no then
you have king f5 gosh darn it that's
nice i still have one
i mean i'm still looking at bishop you
seven ideas they don't work right now
but i will look at them yeah i didn't
want my king
locked in when i go king takes h5 the
one move i don't want to see is the move
king f5
okay so g4 so go back to king jeff why
didn't you play king g4
maybe that is the move yeah you rejected
king g4 yes
instead of king g6 why don't you uh
like yes okay good point
so in this case bishop g5 i'm hopeful
that
h5 h4 and recapturing with the pawn will
will win the game but it also might be
the case
that we get a position where the bishop
is on d6 and
white either has h3 or does or or needs
to keep it right
to force black's bishop into the worst
square
so at no point did we need to play
uh in this way we could have played
bishop d8 for example at some other
point
yes but yes that's always on h2 that's
the problem
well no i like i should date here right
yeah
yeah exactly i like that uh in in this
moment
as well i like bishop to d8 a lot
a lot more than h3 all right this is a
huge game guys
and yes it looks like it looks like my
team does have a technical task ahead
that looks very promising for him
but let's get to the big time game where
anish has done
everything right he has managed to
trade bold decision after queen b3 he
said
yes i'm gonna trade off the dark square
bishops
yes i'm gonna trade off the bishop for
the knight and not e5
instead f4 no not
play solid bishop uh knight on e5
own the board i'm gonna put a knight on
f4 that didn't seem
necessary uh or positionally motivated
it seems far more tactically motivated
i'm not sure
where actually this knight is going from
f4
except sitting there and looking like a
pest
but well it's definitely anish's game
as far as initiative is concerned let's
catch up with the game because we do
have
a lot more moves and it's changed the
dynamics of the position
queen f2 we have here after knight f4
queen f2 queenie eight attacking the
rook c7 first rook before queen e8
attacking the bishop bishop f3 takes on
c4 takes on c4 i'm not really sure that
he needed to do this immediately but
let's see what his idea is because now
i assume queen takes a7 as more or less
force why would i want to be down
material
why did he do this though i mean but how
does this work out does he have a tactic
at the end like for example
well this oh my god does that work
promising attack right
wait does this work like queen a7 rook
a4
queen c7 rook a3 does this work
queen d6 rook f3
takes queen e2 well that looks like it
works
no no no it doesn't queen b1 and queen b
queen b1
ah actually does that defend anyway
um two is still right yeah still hanging
i can't defend that
don't hate that that's unfortunate
that's a very nice uh
winning pattern uh it's funny how
there's a lot of moves i'm not
guaranteeing this works yeah yeah yeah
it's funny how we kind of got to this
position i uh
i mean you guys well rook a4 take a pawn
that's really nice but i'm also looking
at this
and this knight on f4 i was saying that
the knight on e5 could also be leveraged
for attack this looks like domination to
me
i mean even if i play an incredibly
stupid move like f5 and queen e5
with the idea of putting a rook on c2
and a pawn on g4
i i love everything about blacks
it it's survival mode it's survival mode
for carolina
rookie for on the board oh boy guys oh
boy
as a player i'm telling you anish
for this tournament only seven rounds
starting with the fir from round one
has played the best chess of everyone in
this tournament right
and he's continuing to disagree he's got
two wins
two draws he's got this game where he's
punishing white
white has to try to survive he's
dangerous
if he wins this and he's level with
nepo after if never only draws
with two games to go i mean look at this
score he's he's round six
but from round eight draw win draw win
maybe another win and i'll be here with
two rounds to go
i'd be afraid of this man like who wants
to sit in front of him
in his next two games and his last two
he has blocked the black against
gristrick i think and white
against against uh kira
alexenko oh yeah yeah and then i mean
would you discount him for 18. no no no
wow he wins this game wow then
you you might have turned turned the
whole thing around he left grishchick
with black
and who we know that could be any kind
of game and alexenko with white
to close it out nippo will feel the heat
if this result
is a plus for geary he's playing great
chess right now
well let's take a look at the variations
queen c7 are because we kind of threw
that around very quickly
i wasn't guaranteeing it worked does it
work queen's history
f3 certainly works does it yeah okay
well you have to take with the pawn
and then queen down i mean everything is
desperation after that i guess it's not
that it's
the rope because it's me yeah so you
have to take with the pawn
and that's a made on g2 you cannot move
the rook because of the queen f3
so that's a given so you're a lost
i mean you only have two checks either
d8 which does nothing
useless or v8 which is not great and now
after that you only have one check
then you stop the check so all that's
done and it's the persistent threat of
queen g2
there's nothing to look at it's over
which means fabi now sees that
and if you see this with how many moves
left queen f2 played by the way saying i
cannot take
on d6 so let's just move the queen back
but that's
strategic advantage material advantage
and initiative for black
that's what i was saying about
desperation mode when you have no time
left and you realize that tactic
is on the board again what is the move
number guys
rook a4 is move 35. he has more moves
so he's got four more moves with six
minutes and
had to ditch a pawn and anish with
13 minutes on the clock guys that's uh
a very bad sign for fabi absolutely
terrible
this is a lost position now bad bishop
bad king down upon less active pieces
and just throughout h4
wow smells of desperation but maybe now
what a move to see on the board now now
white is in is just in
wish mode yeah exactly h4
uh not that i had a better suggestion
but that just
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you were mentioning a moment ago uh
something like g6 and
using the h file and this is one of the
reasons why we were just
kind of like not going with uh h4
h3 not not good guys
uh fabulous looking uh
talking about anish and
his very impressive play and success it
very often happens that
at these candidate events like you you
just
you need to get lucky to win them and
when i think about
the game on each one with dingler and
i mean nobody's giving him anything he's
taking it he's played
he played really really a good game
yesterday
sacrificing the bishop and in the style
that he's played
he he's had great success but
his games have been really impressive
too and even magnus carlson
said that was a great game and let's add
to that
it so happens that we see players
trend positive for a certain period of
time in their career
we've seen many players do this well
magnus has done it often bobby did it as
well
wesley so famously did it when he broke
2 800
that magical year uh when he won the
grand chester breathing yeah yeah right
we see fat we see anish tying for first
this year at tata steel though he did
lose on tie breaks but he played
wonderful classical chess throughout we
see him winning an event he normally
wouldn't win
the magnus cross invitational a rapid
event that means your
instincts are on point when you do that
you can just play quickly and well
and now we see him doing he's trending
positive
here we see him having a dominating
performance so far he's at plus two he's
already gained ten rating points
by the way from four rounds and this is
going to be some more raiding points
look at that queen move whenever you see
pieces appear on the opposite color of
the bishop
this is when you start being a little
bit afraid you look at that queen on e5
the knight on that f4 the rook on a3
the only piece now we need is a king on
g7 to make the bishop say
can i get to the party someday somehow
no
no targets for you that's a dead piece
and this is looking horrible right now
for white
by the way on the um today in chess
green board
i'm seeing a barometer and that
barometer is
a larger and larger black i mean
it's kind of it doesn't make a move and
it just kind of drops yeah
it's like like the longer the computer
gets to to to
to think about the position unless it
seems to like it for
white no for fabby fans and we include
ourselves of course
uh this is not not good
uh for unniches fans they want to ask us
is is nepa winning can ken wang how
save the game somehow wang house saved a
pawn
decided not to go take it because the
king would enter the game right
and i think that was the practical
decision right because we thought about
just going and after the pawn after the
move
a6 and we
we've reached the position now so nepo
could in alpha zero mode uh
put a spawn on h3
um i'd like it actually i like the pawn
on h3 what do you think of them
apples i think the question just the
only question here is
do you have something against a7 that
finished us
finishes off the game if you don't wang
how could hold
okay so kind of comes down to 93 right
okay let's say i just wait what what
does white do for a move
um that might not be the oh he might
just say but i can move my knight right
like yeah
what's the problem like oh you
that's the point of a7 yeah i guess you
can move your night
although no uh yeah you can move the
knight
okay okay there are no mating
constructions with the knight in rook
where knight goes to e3 and you can talk
about some kind of
some kind of mating idea although
93 yeah i i with you the maurice i mean
this position is so bad for white
that i'm starting to think i can allow
you to queen the pawn
and i'll have you know a construction of
a mating net by the time i get my pawn
to d3
and my rook on the second rank god this
is really
gross uh my instant tells me it's lost
with upon the current position after
rook
a8 i'm thinking h3
but maybe white should but the a7 move
is is
oh no i think h3 a7 is forced there's no
way you give up to say
i agree i agree here we need to
uh yeah i'm i'm
eyeballing d3 as well as knight e3
if i played knight e3 and i forced you
to take it that was the mating
construction
i was referring to but then king f1
right that's the problem kingdom i mean
they should force you to go g4
g for night and night yeah
and this is the the thing are you sure
your queen
can defend against the rook and knight
combination
this looks i'm like my
my my queen i'm thinking you're gonna
take
and you're gonna go check and i was
going to take the rook
and then it would be rook and knight
versus your queen but it's your king
that's in trouble by the way h3 are on
the board this one's getting more and
more
tense i mean as nepo tries to win this
game
i can only imagine the audience in
russia is like
i mean the crowd is sensing
uh a challenger a russian challenger
apparently there
but a7 looks looks rough rough to beat
it's just not clear at all
really and meantime uh fabian
g5 yes prop which gonna
naturally prompt queen takes g5 and
there's
only some kind of tactic along the f
file that fabi can hope for
right but where does he put his bishop
d1 uh i threw out
e4 but okay d1 or e4 no okay
maybe the problem with d1 is
um i was about to say asked and answered
uh check check this out queen h6 work h3
is that one yeah that works oh i love
finding stuff like this
oh my word that means that works on all
of them
except bishop g4 yeah
only bishop g4 stops that he has taken
on
g5 and he's that much closer there's two
moves before time control
bobby down to 151 and the wolves
are circling right now as those threats
you mentioned
who knows which other threats exist
that fabi has to worry about with his
bishop he can't play king g1
because of knight to h3 with check so
there's no auto king move to get your
king off this
precarious looking square so it looks
like
oh and you can't even move your queen
away with threats because of rook takes
f3
so queen can't go anywhere far because
rook f3 wins on the spot
so i mean what do you do you might just
you just did
bishop g4 we mentioned is the only way
to stop that
that nice threat that nice tactic you
pointed out alejandro yeah
but beautiful tactic by the way uh
against bishop g4
i'm a pawn grubber on or
i mean maybe it's not the clinical way
the right
one played by the way guys but uh
grabbing uh two extra pawns
[Music]
it sure looked good enough uh to my eyes
rook e1 okay gabby just
quickly fabi's just holding on grimly
uh rook a8 just covering the back rank
so that that's
the real quick move yeah he wants to
make time control
himself without playing spoiling
and you have an hour to relish the
position
and make his opponent suffer he's not
banking on winning and time pressure
or anything like that you're going to
say you have no moves
i'm winning this position if i'm going
to become a challenger
if i can't win this then i don't deserve
to be
exactly so let me just be solid be
reasonable
cover everything and go grind you down
your position is horrible it is
it is the next move by the way
i just uh for our audience at knights
love
protected squares to my mind
i put my knight on e5 in a heartbeat for
those of you who want to play moves like
queen h6 and g5 i understand you
your knights love protected squares but
with this move rook
a8 by the way i mean not to you know
pile on
to fabi's woes because they're
definitely there but knight d3
is definitely a threat
by the way i'm being told
i'm here properly
yeah what's going on napo uh
game is over or hold on
uh where we think that there might be a
result in that no i can't no
there is no reason it's old i mean
you're slack today
this is not correct we've been talking
the game is over how about we get told
the result
i would say white one yeah well
why would you resign you'd like like to
see
the the finishing technique i i believe
it's there don't get me wrong but
you don't just resign
we'll come back to it uh back to fabi
for a moment he we just played the move
bishop e4
by the way i i mean not that i like the
move but
i do fully understand what fabi wants to
do if that knight
moves to g6 get rid of that bishop
he's not going to get that opportunity
i'm afraid
a g6 maybe
g6 i hear g6
g6 looks kind of good i i'm only worried
about rook f1 right
i mean there's only there's only one
thing that white could really do that
could be upsetting
is the move rook f1 and
maybe night here just put your knight on
protected square
so that there is no rook f1
what do you think about them apples
something like i don't know
this
i see that officially i got a one zero
and uh i'm assuming
that he brought his king all the way
over here to g4
before carroll resigned and by the way i
i think for carol this was a game that
you know yeah there's so many things i
disliked about this game for carol
that uh we remind everybody the way he
lost to nepo
which was one of those games you know i
don't mind losing but i want to learn
something from my losses this is not a
game where
he really put up any kind of sterling
resistance
he's actually playing he's actually
collapsing in the second half
and that bodes well for people who have
to play him like one on each geary
seeing
okay i get you in the last round and
you're not playing well
so and with high hopes there look at
maxime just
find it his way how how is maxime
right now only a half a point out of
first we suspect he will be a full point
but still the guy is bleeding and and
he's still somehow marching ahead
and he gets this match up tomorrow
amazing
destiny with somebody who has been his
customer
uh incredible the the tournament needed
to see maxim win
now certainly aneesh is saying that's
that's a good result
uh don't don't keep going too hot but
just at least take care of this guy for
me
while i keep up my pace big time result
here
for maxime for the for the tournament
it it surely does that um
yeah guys i i mean i i i'm not laughing
really really i'm not laughing i just
think
it's remarkable that somebody's having
such a topsy
turvy second half as mbl he started
uh with a critical loss in round eight
to fabiano
uh you know like we thought oh that
definitely spoiled his chances
goodbye maxine and yet he's still in it
with a shout this is great
by the way that 1-0 is just wrong get
rid of that onesie the guys are playing
no no no no they they they haven't i've
been told the game ended and they're
just updating the board
oh they're updating they're updating
what happened the board just like grows
we'll have to see i think
we'll take more of that some problems
but okay in this position with fabi i
was just thinking yes let's go can you
go rook a2
rook a2 that is a great move
yes it's perfectly good because
this is a winning at the game
on the spot
yeah i i think the way it works with us
guys
alejandro especially you it's like uh
you know as the round goes longer
you start waking up reminding everybody
that it's early morning in st louis and
that's
you get the tactical eye
[Laughter]
your last move in the back rank is an
issue so
what if the bishop drops back they're
awake in florida
and for myself speaking of myself my
behalf
all i got to do is show what you guys
are thinking
i look good did you see bishop b1
alejandra no but okay
g6 looks so positionally unmotivated
you played the move i would play and now
rook
and now rook a2 start because g6 i think
yasser's point was rook f1 we needed to
move against that right
i mean there might exist but i haven't
seen it yet right and i was just sitting
there saying
like if if if i'm looking for black side
here and i don't know
what are you guys talking about rook f1
mates yourself
oh well
put it like a 92 business
maybe i got too much credit for waking
up yeah queen age 5 92
you're back
yeah that's nice that's a nice pattern
that is pretty
so g6 that might just be
all right if you cannot play rook f1
against g6 that's oh
yeah yeah yeah absolutely put the king
on
well you don't even need to put the king
anywhere anymore but if you can play g6
and just emphasize how useless a piece
the bishop is
terrible terrible terrible terrible
i don't know i mean if i have to play
a move like g3 and i don't know
you know like pray that i could do
something like this i don't believe it
whatsoever i think it's just losing oof
but that was some nice stuff guys i
liked what you guys were doing there
with the rook a2 bishop b1
and g6 and queen h5 very nice
very interesting even in super desperate
positions
there's always a trick right that's the
thing about chess it doesn't matter how
bad your position sometimes says
kind of find an idea and as long as you
have those ideas you keep on playing
one of the one of the games i will never
forget it
it was a candidates i was playing in
montpellier
in 1985 and it was the game between
zoltan ribley and boris baskey look it
up because it was such a
an amazing finish zoltan ribley's pawn
up and a queen ending and he is just
doing the nasty to boris boris just
doing everything he could to hang on and
zoltan has played like i don't know
80 beautiful moves he plays one move
that allows a stalemate trick
and spassky finds it
zoltan's sad frozen
like in absolute shock you know there's
always a trick right
okay two was played tell me okay
two was played it's on the board it's
not the end of the world right bishop
one you can go back to
you gotta go back yeah that's a little
bit of a startler you put a work on a2
and the guy says
bishop back one what did you do man he's
fortunate there's no other square for
this bishop
hold on is there anything
sorry guys can i just see this
i mean i i'll i'll borrow a page from
your books
you combined us i combined you
combination i'm taking the best of
alejandro
the best of maurice
mixing mixing it together and and
cooking bishop
b1 rook a2 is a winner that actually
means bishop d3
is the only way to play bishop
let's combine
the same threats as if you're guarding
e2
and the a2 is singing and everybody's
hanging
that's crazy oh that's fine no that's
insanity right
well maybe i don't mean i don't know i
don't see the refutation but
i'm still so just a second hold on wait
what if i just think
what if i just take the bishop rookie
thank you no rookie 8 and queen takes
there's no mate there is there a back
there's no mate for sure but yeah
there's nothing there's nothing issues
whether it is a back rank
thing but i don't see anything no
doesn't exist i was going in a different
direction guys i was going in this kind
of a direction
now of course you can't go to f1 you
can't go to h2
i've covered a2 but
it's funny how nothing about this
changes the position you're still not
all right it's weird right yeah so
bishop to d3 that is a
that's a bizarre looking move okay i
agree that i do have
rook uh back to a8 but
didn't i then win a tempo because then
you i
unfortunately shipped the e3 rook aid
bishop bishop is not exactly
comfortable on the t3 square no no
it's not like oh look what square i
found i always wanted
to square it always [ __ ] of d3 looks
like
i was dreaming dreaming of d3
but does he have another move
that's really oh but wait bishop c2
think about bishop z2 is that g6
probably picks up the bishop soon right
yes uh i would say
pretty soon i don't really want to be
yeah looking for some alternative to the
bishop d3 looks
so funny looks like you you're sticking
your
nose right at the guy's fist yeah like
right like
find some kind of tactic but
maybe it's your only move possible
although fabi's sitting there thinking i
don't want to play them
i know i mean what am i doing it's not a
real trick because
black clearly has defenses against this
i mean at least he forces the rook to go
back but
what are you gonna do next put the
bishop back on e4 you're gonna put it on
f1 maybe
maybe bishop f1 but d5 is always hanging
d5 is always hanging oh boy
um i think you could just go back to aaa
force the bishop back to e4 i really
don't see a better move than that
well and then you guys can see that g6
business if uh
if you're not happy and i tell you i
would be
happy happy about putting this knight on
the g3 square
as well nike by the way big development
big development there as we see bobby
finds his move the nepo game
the move g4 got played by white
interesting where knight we thought
was just curtains from delicious
but knight d2 would be played in that
event
and instead he decided to play knight to
d6 yeah actually i i might be
misremembering but i thought knight h4
we just left it on uh we don't know if
the queen is good enough to defend
against the knight on the rook but it
might be right
um yeah we we we hadn't come to a
conclusion
also the problem is i i don't think we
even had a really good
suggestion for this but okay knight d6
no but then you got king f1 what do you
mean
whoops oh sorry sorry sorry sorry uh
then you go king f1 what do you mean
yeah because i no longer need to give up
my
i don't need to promote with rookie a
check like if you take on d2
knight f3 is not okay so just a second
just a second i was gonna
i one thing's for sure alejandro you're
really happy this isn't
your position i mean you didn't have
anything
to do with it amazingly
i'm hoping for the best right yeah
exactly no this is not looking
knight c4 let's keep trying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
golly it's shocking that there isn't
just a stone cold
easy way here but okay fair enough
because i know what i would say if i
were if i were
black if i were white is the move in
that position g5
sorry we've got no no i'm sorry to our
audiences uh push
king no no no sorry
when you play knight g2 maybe g5 is a
strong move for you but knight g2
you like this move okay okay and then
you just said no no please make another
move no no no not as not as black
as white
i apologize i didn't understand because
i don't want the black king to
to run anywhere so the first check with
with my nike and somehow
well i don't see how exactly but the
funny thing is i think you're an actual
zuk swinging if i play yeah
yeah exactly now you three king e1 and i
play something like
but wait am i also in zucks
[Laughter]
because where do i put my king king this
seven runs into cafe
yeah this is silly this is serious
i remember i was lubash cavallic
who was the first player i i was working
with lubash we were preparing for an
interzonal in mexico
into zonal and taluka mexico and uh
lubash had
had a joy for study uh problems and he
introduced me i i never had this concept
in my life
of mutual zugzwa i just thought that was
like hilarious zuku swan and i
understood completely
like zuk's wrong you're going to lose
you've got to you've got to make a move
that
worsens your position so i understood
zuke zwonk but the idea that both
players could be in zigzag
mutuals you know the funny thing is
hilarious we we
all know a mutual zug song that's super
basic
um king and pawn ending king and pawn
and games exactly
yeah yeah that's a mutual zucchini i
never
looked at it that way i looked at it
right the guy's just drawing or
something you know
but that was very funny this position uh
if it's white to move you know you could
give him one move
yeah you could say okay you could put
your and then give white the move
again somehow you make a series of moves
and then you realize you can't move the
rook you can't move the knight then
the knight were to move it's mate on the
spot so that's
very hilarious well actually let's get
up to the game does have the move f4 in
this position
it's key actually yeah that's key for
white as well to have a free move
but instead this big moment
rook after knight d6 rook to b8 that's a
statement move
because it's giving away the a pawn you
must take it
yeah you cannot allow a eight queens
interesting that he's thinking after
rook v8
so yes this is like a grishchuk rule you
must take it
and then rook to b4
and and you must then play d3
because knight b5 is not on top and
knight f5 is not possible
so you must play d3 to keep it oh and i
can play rook back
yeah right b3 just for collecting three
i was thinking d4 but rook b3
and uh give me the pawn it's just a draw
right
a little unpleasant but still just to
draw no
just checking to make sure because again
i'm looking at this
i mean unless i have some very very
concrete way of
putting my knight on f2 well if we're
gonna do this i'd rather
have white's rook be on d4 so it's not
defending f3
so just do it from the beginning right
it's possible right
yeah exactly now play this and takes and
check and move and run
but knight d 92 is not playable
yeah that's a problem king g1 is coming
next
unless you had a knight move like no
knight b5 is the only disrupter move
and rook to d3 will be always good
so how bad is the end game after knight
c4
man there i mean you're talking about
tricks there's always tricks alejandro
you find a move like nights
i'm very tricky i mean i might not have
any positional concepts but i'm pretty
tricky
that's that that's a visual i can say so
the idea of course
is you want to get into a rook upon and
maybe i don't know what things you want
this is like
ugly three versus two this is it's an
ugly one
i think murray's wanted to play king
without mercy one but i still play rogue
g2 and i
at least pick up a pawn right so
yeah i don't know can we back up can we
back up because i wanted i wanted to
know the effect of rookie for check
so 92 94 rook e4 check
right now rook edgar let's say i just
get out of dodge
okay okay why they're not at least at
least i got your king to have to back up
because on f6 i wanted to be able to
look at four check and save the pawn so
that was the point
but you say you save what phone i'm
sorry to defend the f pawn if it ever
comes to pass
right yeah oh actually no you're you
never save it because it's always a
checkmate threat
you're tempering on my rook yeah all
right so that's a that's a big point
yeah no that's a big point uh
napo uh is thinking
in this exact moment what you're saying
guys that uh
if you're gonna you're giving back the
d-pawn give back the d-pawn when the
rook is on d4 and
not on f3 so this is the moment that
we're considering
rook a2 and
it's the best way to play it looks like
yeah so let's see it rook a2
right because this is hyper critical
rook takes d4 jack
rook threatening
the knight as well as the pawn that's
why we played knight d2
maybe i have to play king g1 but knight
d2
alejandro's knight c4 very visual move
indeed
right if rook takes rook takes
threatening mate
we tried king maybe can we give up the
h-pawn
yeah i was just wondering that but can
you
and let's say i make a move here
just pass but no i don't think i can
actually so
why don't you play g5 no but g5 drops
the pawn
but that's okay if we can go in here and
rook takes
ah okay okay that's a good that's a good
move maurice i like
g5 but what if i go okay hold on okay
that that actually no but now i go check
on g2 and i pick up the pawn
and i have h5 at the end right and then
this case
yes yeah rook h5 or rook g3
oh boy oh boy oh boy but
this one yeah i'm not surviving that
right i'll bring it i am
not i am not surviving
[Music]
beautiful okay so let's keep going
because
are we saying it's winning yeah this is
ending at that point it's winning
but this one looks terrible
[Music]
[Laughter]
my king is stuck uh
not moving and black's king is making
that looks lost right totally followed
by
by the way bobby played rook b1 no no
tricky bishop move
no but that's also very tricky you're
attacking the rook and you're attacking
checkmate how did we not consider rook
v1
should always be considered yes i have a
stream
i i have a stream on i stream on twitch
and uh i found a game where rook b1 was
played in the most
obscure circumstance because this is
profound
game where rook b1 is played in a moment
when black plays it so that
sorry white plays rook b1 so that when
black plays knight takes c3
and wins the c pawn the rook is sitting
on b1 saying yeah go ahead
but white but it's not like black has to
play knight c3
but rook b1 is prophylaxis against
knight takes c3 like if you take on c3
mirror get to b5 it actually did happen
in the game and this rook b1
move turned out to be fantastic and it
was blue black off the board
king was still in the middle and we're
crashing on b7 etc
and my stream loved it so much that
rugby one became
our pet movement and if you ever see
rook be one it's like oh my
god like a money maker you know it's
like a straight money maker people are
like oh we love it
tip him that's great maurice another we
want to see more v1 could you please
make
uh a an emote could you please make a
t-shirt
we want to cap with rugby i mean there
are such fans of the move rook be one
that anytime i see it i'm sure those who
are watching now are thinking
maurice you got a rook b1 on the board
fabi must be back
donation donation time only if only i
was streaming right now so i could get a
donation
but rugby won here uh on the board and
we
and the fact that i didn't see it makes
me feel like uh
dude rookie ones you're screaming about
stuff
that's my money maker right there you
have to go back i think right
i mean it's terrible because you are now
threatening to take the rook you are
threatening mate
and that's what we're maybe rook a2
well i mean you got a style point it
didn't certainly didn't cost you
anything the job done and and fabi took
what 20 minutes
or how long did fabi take as a response
to rook a2
it took a while right yeah so no harm no
foul
if no harm no foul you got 20 minutes
that you
exactly put the right back and say you
know what you're right
i'll reset i'll reset it's not a problem
you know what though hold on
i can't so i hope
it also refutes the thing about rugby
one is it refutes queen h5
yes because there's no check and check
right
exactly it's a it's a very slick trap
uh you know a lot of check and ooh i get
a check and it's over and then suddenly
the move queenie two lands on the board
and
uh instead of you mating your opponent
you start crying
and your queen your rook and mate are
all hanging in one move
this is once again you know that frozen
moment of terror you feel when you
realize
you plundered the whole game in one move
you know oh dear evil chess
is cruel um yeah i think we're going
back
we're we're backpedaling here but
remember we're sitting here calmly
saying you know what backpedal play g6
go
giri knows that as well but when you're
in the heat of the moment you've played
rook a2
i think he resigns and then the guy
plays a simple rook b1
and you might be unnerved slightly
you have to keep you have to come you
have to completely erase that feeling
of sort of self-recrimination
that you made a move that you didn't see
the response
that's the thing you've seen everything
up to this point and suddenly he plays a
movie you go
what i'm stupid and you have to get over
that feeling of
i'm stupid so you can make your next
move and continue and just win the game
right
i i think in this case i don't have a
problem personally retracting my
previous move especially
the no arm no foul but so yeah but my
problem as a player i just wanted to say
was carrying the the baggage
of earlier play like if i was winning
right and you know somehow i spoiled it
and the game's even i've lost
objectivity i'm still
thinking i gotta win this game because i
was winning 20 minutes with 20 moves
before
press you know but okay taking back
a move i you know like i i'm one check
the guy defendant and i go oh darn
you know i gotta go back i don't have
problems with that it's that
you know feeling like i'm supposed to be
winning because i was winning earlier
that that had me in knots but
you know the thing is anish was playing
a perfect game
perfect game right yeah like he was
playing wonderful chess okay maybe
perfect game is really really the right
way to because professionally
oh no he's he's playing his body but as
well as any um
boss yeah the last thing you want to do
is in the middle of playing like a boss
and every move is just stringing
together your artistic
masterpiece look what i'm doing to this
guy are you guys watching this
oh look what i'm doing it's for you to
make a move and then the guy makes me go
i don't know that just i didn't see that
that really spoiled things and well okay
maybe he doesn't spoil things men to
back up
do i have to back up maybe there's a
trick he missed is there another move in
the position
uh damn i really do have to back up man
that was kind of dumb why did i do that
i gave him an extra move
maybe i gave him a different move can he
improve another way am i starting to see
go
you know okay if you're a professional
you go
i back up and you're still busted that's
the reality
but white got two free moves i got a
bishop on e4
rook rook on it b1
it don't really help it doesn't
effectively help but you get the
feeling that that was more luck than
anything else right
by the way by the way you want a funny
one
yeah i think it's funny rook a8
queen a2 or a7
just i think i'd rather go to a2 but but
you know something like this
and you go all right i had the a file 2
and he just took over the a file
yeah you know i have to move the rook
away
and thank goodness there's no rook b8
just hold on hold on is there no rupee
what's happening here
no i mean i think most moves are in here
i do too i mean
that's clean enough exactly exactly
exactly yeah well i think
uh alejandro it's time to sneak in a
little commercial here
it's actually our first break of the day
so maybe it's a good time to do it just
ask some of these end games they're
they're heating up
uh we haven't even gotten to the end
game of christopher dingle and we'll do
that right after we get back
but guys huge results let's take a break
before we have
anish give make his rook a decision
we'll be
right back with the action
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major
error instead boogie through the city
and discover the music that gave the
blues their name
at the national blues museum broadway
oyster bar or even the legendary
blueberry hill
so whether you love the cardinals the
blues or the blues
come play with us and you guys know i
can't play this
right st lou is always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
[Music]
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized health
care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen listening to you
caring for you we are ascension
be surprised be intrigued
be delighted the world chess hall of
fame in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame mind art
experience
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri
is steeped in tradition the recently
founded mizzou chess program
is a partnership between the university
of missouri and the st
louis chess club collegiate jess has
been experiencing a meteoric rise at the
national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institution's
ethos of respect
responsibility discovery and excellence
to the chessboard
professional golf returns to st louis in
2021
the ascension charity classic presented
by emerson
stars like phil mickelson ernie else jim
furyk and more compete at norwood hills
country club september 6 through the
12th tickets clubhouse passes
hospitality suites and pro-am foursomes
are on sale now
all proceeds go to north st louis county
charities visit
ascensioncharityclassic.com
or call 314-938-2828 pga tour golf is
back in the louvre
the ascension charity classic
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back here with round 12.
let's take the
look at the current standings with one
game finish
this was maxima sherlock that defeated
kirill alexenko
pretty clean game honestly basically
taking a pawn from the opening
and that's kind of holding him to
currently second place but let's
remember that hyannis
and especially anishgiri still have
their eyes on a full
point uh fabio carona with six points
he's
barely trying to survive and at some
point we should take a look at alexander
grisham's game
against dingley wren as he also has five
and a half points
and well mathematically he's not
eliminated but it definitely
a tough road ahead guys what's happened
in
our break well uh
not that much in any of the games uh
frankly speaking anishkeri is completely
winning i mean
completely winning against fabi he did
after this nice move rook b1
uh reset himself he played the move rook
a2 rook e1
and here i'm just thinking that this
knight is going to go to g3
knight back to h5 to g3 uh
looks decisive uh the big one anyway he
refuses to play g6
like he why doesn't he just play g6
i don't have to he's burned a lot of
clock and a lot of energy and a lot of
angst
and scaring his fans after one landing
on the board
and refuses to play the move g6
which looks so straightforward
especially after you see rook f1
queen h5 check is winning that's the
nice uh
uh line could have played rockefeller
immediately so
right exactly so why don't you play g6
and say dude you're gonna get served
i'm turning 42 again yeah and which
actually works
yeah yeah it's over
why hasn't he played g6 and he's allowed
his clock to also take down to fobbies
right in fact he's going to go under
fabi's time now
the other thing about g6 is that
we've seen this before king h2
rook a2 the idea is you've got this
check
to pick up the rook which picks up the
bishop so yeah at g6
looks really really good i think nothing
to talk about let's look at the nepo
game because why so
what i'm saying to talk about alejandro
is why hasn't he done it
why rook 828 took him a while he had the
chance to play g6 earlier he had this
position before
he did not play it what is he thinking
about
i think he may be enjoying the position
he's just like oh this is so delicious
let's not rush
and uh g6 but okay uh let's continue
because we haven't gotten to see
grishok or dinglerand but first of all
nepo our tournament leader
um we thought
back here that nepo had some chances
we're not 100
sure about his decision to put the rook
on d3
i guess the difference was that he can
now play knight to c4
isn't it time that we get this knight
off the back rank guys knight to g3
yeah um this one is more like drawing
than
previously sorry they're like lisandro g
i'll fall for it whatever it is i just
don't see it i'm trying to set it up but
i'm trying to get some way that i can
take on f3 after rook f2
so that you could go here and but i
don't even know what i'm threatening
honestly if you give me a free move
right
uh so let me give you a free move g5
yeah
and maybe you don't have to give me a
free move like you can actually organize
the defense with rookie three
rookie too true
yeah i'm just thinking that if i get an
f4
and somehow unmask an attack against
this pawn on h3
are going to get to trade off some pawns
and that's what
what precipitated uh g5
uh also f4
i don't know yeah no i don't i don't see
it
i don't see it either frankly
but let's take a look at the game that
we have been
oh my gosh i was about to say the one
thing
when i when we'd left it it was like
basically here
and it was kind of funny because i'm
thinking that the one thing i want to
avoid as black
is i don't want to take this night when
the knight can
quickly hop to the d4 square i see that
d4 square
is just like you know worth terrible
gorgeous gorgeous gobs of material
a knight on d4 versus a very passive
knight i don't want to take on e5
i thought the move queen anywhere
backwards to
defend the c6 pawn was necessary he did
play bishop takes e5 which for me
is a strategic howler and after de
9792 i'm sorry guys the position is just
strategically really bad
i'm unless i'm less i'm
i'm he's planning to sacrifice a
and knight why not and though in the
wise words of ben larson right
nobody believes you but still
again it's like a classic and it killed
me at the time it
it's still killing me um yeah
uh what can i say this is not why you
played bishop takes e5
but give me another give me a move i
mean
that was the only move massively i go
here
exactly at a certain time i'll go king
here
queen here and f5 and then i'll resign
that's it i'll just resign those moves
play themselves
and this knight on d4 is overwhelmingly
superior to the knight on d7
if i don't play knight c5 i don't have a
chance but i don't
believe i have much of a chance even
after i do sacrifice a piece
looks like dingler in
well you know he could be
spoiling a lot of people's results but
okay
anisha's not removed by the way i just
i don't think we ever pointed it out but
the final
oh yeah here it is uh the the the way
that
maxine won the position at the very end
deserves mention where is it come on
how come my board is not popping up
there it is
okay uh just at the very end because we
were thinking that
it it needed some nice finessing
as it turned out we got you remember
this position
yeah oh that's easy bam
yeah oh and king here and
bishop here and he resigned because
the whole point was that after this
this this this
this you get zugzwang
that's just nice it's like go ahead
your turn if you move your king i'm
going to play f5 if you move your bishop
i'm going to collect the whole queen
side so e5 and king e4 that goes to show
this ending was
really really lost guys we just have
nothing going on here
at at all let's switch back to by the
way anish did move and he said
no g6 solidity i don't need it because
i'm now going to play a beasty shot
f5 instead wow i mean
that's a confident man it's a move that
fabi wants to see right
yeah yeah i i definitely
would have gone for the g6 i don't like
it but okay
but maybe it's just it's just very very
concrete
forceful smash mouth chest so bishop f3
knight d3 i guess is game over
yep that's a fork don't see any
anything because queen e3 queen h4 so
so that's that takes care of that and if
you've got to go the
other way now
89 g2 maybe does that work that
that's exactly what i'm thinking maybe
it doesn't work that's right
uh king no
no i don't i was no sorry
sorry sorry okay let's just pause for
just a second here
how can we play king
sure you can maybe go back to a3
i beg your pardon like rook a3 again
rook a3 again cause the rook was there
already but
but sorry uh did we have a reputation
f7 i'm still this looks this looks
pretty nasty the g2 is hanging queen
can't leave
rook check you can't leave the diagonal
even you can't play any move that allows
queen h4
so you'd have to go to d2 to guard both
that's the only move
that guards both but it lines you up for
another tactic
so the oldest guy what do you do rick h8
is just
on its way you can't move your queen
you have to you can't move your king you
can't move your queen
rook h8 knight h3 is coming somebody has
to guard h3 so
rook e3 is the only way to d
is the only if that loses then you're
dead
um which i don't doubt you're dead but
yeah because i hear enrique won but
actually
even sorry if you're going to be
mean about it what can i say
that's pretty darn mean is it over yeah
i think so
that's really great b3 b3 queen h5 queen
d1 queen b3
oh it's a queen d1 problem gotcha and uh
rook rookie one g6 you just got no moves
man like nobody's moving
real on the fast
somebody's moving the queen's not moving
there's
mate the rook is the bishop can't move
because then there's the mate the the
rook can't move
nobody's moving depressing very
difficult wait what did we do i don't
understand
what what happened f5 was met by
which bishop beef juan is not in the
kingdom
sorry bishop b1 king f7 was made by rook
to e3
yes that was and actually what is the
problem with rook check and night check
i'm just curious
nothing i mean
i'm assuming that rook a1 was just a
cleaner win no but this is very clean
queen c1 queen f1 queen e3 i'm not even
going to joke
yeah yeah
so f5 is uh
a smash mouth chest yeah that's why he
went deep into the tank there was no way
he went deep into the tank
because g6 was on his mind that's just
basic chest
he went in there to calculate the
forcing nature of the move f5
and found that this is just winning at
least by his estimation
a complex move to be sure but
looks great like just five is the move
of a very confident man let me just say
that
you know i mean g6 i think a lot of
grand masters would have convinced
themselves that was the best move on the
board and you don't spoil
any it may have been it may have been it
may have been but f5
is really also like wow
i don't know alejandro what's your take
between the two moves f5 g6
i i think g6 to me
looks more sane but i totally understand
that if you're strong enough
a niche to calculate out f5 and you see
a win you just do it
i've been burned enough where i make
this good calculation and i expose my
king and everything is
under control and then suddenly it isn't
g6 i'm with you 100 i think everybody
has been in that
situation where you can make this you
know very comfortable g6 set up
everything
and instead you've exposed your king for
what you thought and calculated as you
said
forcing win only to discover there was a
fly in the ointment
at the end but uh there's no fly here
guys i mean
i don't see a better move than bishop b1
because we had to defend against knight
d3
and then uh somebody came up with uh
king f7 rook e3
check and let it shack this is not
genius
just give me the exchange yeah give me a
free whole exchange
don't trade queen takes f5 this is just
no no no no
hopeless hopeless and you're dead listen
you
we we talked about it before in
in chess sometimes there's the best move
we would like to play the best
naturally but what this generation has
learned
is that the engines show sometimes
there's more than one desk move in fact
often
there's more than one best move it'll
evaluate and say
you could have done this or you could
have done that you could have done that
all of those and he has to play king of
seven
all of those lead to wins or all of this
is equal whichever one it all depends on
the circumstances your opponent
your style of play your preference it's
on you
it's you don't have to play just one
move now that g6 move
we all know what you just said the fear
factor you go i expose my king
something could happen right g6
nothing's gonna happen f5 something
could happen on the way to the wind
that i don't want to have happen it's
happened before
but a clear confident thinker
or people who weren't punished as often
as we have for making these
aggressive moves where you could have
played solidly in one anyway
i go but f5 is winning right like i play
f5 i play king of seven you have to
resign though
the the threats are monstrous you're
just gonna super handsome
i did it all with tempo he didn't even
lose time he didn't say g6 your move
he said f5 your bishop's hanging move it
now my king moves rook check is coming
what are you gonna do
pure straightforward black to move and
win f5
even if g6 were mathematically better f5
is just
winning and that's all right part three
mathematically better than winning
yeah so what you were saying there also
maurice it always intrigued me like
replaying over some of my games i
remember the those moments where
you know i was trying to calculate a win
versus playing a very strong move and
just going on
and it's sort of like a lot of times the
engines just say
okay this is plus five this is plus four
this is plus
four and as you were saying there
there's no real best moves all moves are
winning
uh in this case it seems to me to be a
stylistic
by the way rook e3 on the board i
think fabby's gonna throw in the towel
when he sees knight h
pardon me rook h a check and knight h3
um going back to dingler in for just a
moment again us
apologies that is a game that we
didn't wait what didn't look at where
where
is wait what happened f6 and e5
what what did he just commit side suey
like
why would you f6 what
wait what's the point e5 he wanted to
stop knight d4
i guess but that's one way of doing it
so if i if i take on g7 what
where's the counter spiel
don't see much of the counter stuff
before maybe and then you take
oh i gotta take that one too just keep
munching
hey how many points is that there you go
wait wait wait wait wait wait just leave
out a tree maybe
i don't know maybe there was one trick
rookie chain played by the way in the
foggy game let's get back to it
will fobby continue to make moves after
rook to h a check
because he can clearly see kg1 knight h3
check is resigned so
are we on a death no he did move king to
g1 and we're waiting for a knight h3
check
which ends the game is there a mate
along the file
queen h6 king f1
for some strange reason uh i'm not able
to
move my uh lee chess i'm not making
lead chess moves for some reason i can't
go
you know we've got the board in front of
us right i do see that that's good
so we got this again knight h3 does it
is there
some other funky way to to hurt the
guy's feelings what about queen
h5 green h5
drops f4 right yeah
so what are we queen h6 maybe
king f1 right is the only move
or or no the queen could move because
what move where though well
like e1 maybe no but queen h1 queen g2
is checkmate
oh that's right you got to guard that so
where do you put it queen
when what are you guys looking at which
which means six in this position maybe
queen b2
after queen x no but still queen h1
queen g2
oh wait wait a minute i'm always getting
hit so maybe queen 86 is better than
knight h3
i mean queen h6 winning is winning
better i don't think
it matters which one you choose so to
speak
but but i you know style i mean style
points
right right the machine gives you more
style of points yeah yeah queen h6 might
give us more style points because what
is your next move
if oh there's queen g3 is the only thing
i haven't refuted yet yeah queen g3 is
possible
and i could play but in that no no queen
h6 queen g3
and i don't get the bishop no no okay so
then i don't want to play it
sorry so i'm going to explain how i how
i blunder these things that way i go
queen h1
yes king f2 rook h2 i'm like
how do you defend that pawn and then
okay i guess zero key seven
i don't know if it's a draw but it's bad
enough
maybe you get to dance but yeah no but
now you're really upset why you ever
played f5 yeah a guy gets to keep moving
pieces
no now you're wondering why you're not
playing he's just
no he's he sees knight h3 guys 93 is
over but he's now looking for style
points
look at that style point again
a confident man plays knight takes g2
wow rook g3
is met by queen c1 what a smash of a
move
now you can't play king takes because of
queen h1 bait
and if you play queen f1 and rook h1
anish is just
lighting it up lighting fire
what a move
oh man what did sasha grisha call it
gangster chess
this is gangsta all day this is my
virginity
this is crushing yeah that is just game
right that's wow
he looked at all the wins and found
the one we were looking for the style
points yeah 33 wins
but style is 192.
maurice you had brought up the line of
the players
you know how they got here and their
road ahead
and it was sort of like you take a look
at anish geary's play
over these last eight ten games
whatever remember it's been from round
16 now
he is he's over but
he's smashing finish wow and his
confidence winning with black
when he needed to against the number two
player on the planet there's only one
player better than fabiano caruana
and that is magnus carlson and anish
said listen i know you were the
challenger
no more you're going wow and now i am on
the road to trying to become
the challenger this is wow incredible
result he is now in clear
first at the moment we don't expect that
to last
after this round but he's in clear first
from losing in the first round from
being at 50
after the first seven rounds
he's just catapulted himself with three
wins out of five games
incredible result for our niche geary
well guys we gotta look at the
network game is he does he have passes
exactly
because suddenly it's like all eyes just
went
wow i am just uh
massive huge um unfortunately
i boldly state the obvious there goes
our boy uh fabi he's these are two year
cycles he's not going to get another
world championship
crack for another two three years
quite a blow quite a disappointing blow
after the fantastic
round eight result guys just talk about
that for a second
because it's now it's a two well and
bl's still in there too right
yes i got an outside chance
what happens between and the supposing
that
nepo disappears what happens in an mvl
versus nepo tiebreaker set up how did
they
envious no you mean nvidia and vl niche
how did they match up i thought they
drew both their games
okay so then it goes to other formulas
okay
it could be annoying back here uh we do
think that that that yan is for choice
obviously
but uh how realistic is it
this doesn't look winning at all well
i'll
i'll make a cheapo i'll play might be
two
and maybe you won't know it as my thread
you
sorry which is the cheapo move knight b2
knight boy two
okay it's there
the cheapo yeah he wants to get a little
knight d1 action
on me okay well uh
well uh g5
you're going to fall for the cheapo i i
just didn't know
how he wants to counter cheapo
yeah no no i'm not going to go there's
the cheapo there's the cheaper
cheapo alert guys uh but this is winning
right
yes it is i i i have to play knight e4 i
think or
i don't understand why is it winning why
because you lost you dropped g5 at the
end like g5
knight d1 rook c8 king g7 knight e4
uh knight f2 yeah you take you take
you throw any checkmate and
in this version of the end game you lose
g5
for free yeah that doesn't sound very
good
that's not attractive
yeah this is over so i don't think you
can go
g5 maybe you do have to start with
knight e4 hold on sorry
just convince me yeah you're going to
get it
is this a absolutely winning
oh you're saying this isn't no maybe not
here take not a hundred percent sure
what what
no that's an easy draw so is that
withdrawal
isn't it yeah maybe it is huh
i mean you've got that yeah no i'm
convinced i'm convinced right right
[Laughter]
king f1 king f1 sorry
no no can you have king e3 king f1
h4 is a draw right because king he took
g3 and anything else i just pushed my
phone
yeah uh i win
no sorry no i want to play king e4 in
that position but then you can
then you get with the pawn on f4
oh sorry you want to do what you came
here
three king f1 i'm sorry h4
yeah because king of one allows king f3
uh
so h4 f4 f4
threading king e2
and now king e4 king f2 and
we have a result in the other game that
we unfortunately didn't put a lot of
attention to
sorry to uh ding lawrence fans but
when we left it it was pretty miserable
for sasha
and they went down what we considered f
takes g7 e4
but diglorant put a break to all that
counterplayed play the move queen c3
saying if you go back with the queen
i'll take on e4 that's very crystal
clear
and queen takes c3 knight takes c3 is a
little bit too many
pawns on that king's side one two
three four right yeah yeah that's too
many
that's right and he just resigned he
just threw in the towel this is just
queen c3 uh cause resignation
yeah yeah well wow
it's not it's not exactly guys this is
the result for the tournament
but at least seeing loren is out of the
cellar this is
i don't know if we've seen this many
rounds
this many victories in a single round
before guys uh
three wins out of now we have not and if
nepo wins
it'll be the first time we have four
decisive results
wow and we've just seen this move knight
b2
setting up this monstrous cheapo
of knight f2 mate as well
as attacking the rook so
uh i played g5 and made it
draw well maybe not you have to make
sure right right it wasn't convincing
this draw it wasn't convincing
okay besides the move uh g5
uh make a suggestion other another
suggestion
there's two ways to stop this that i can
see there's knight e4
on there's rook c8 which he played rook
c8 king g7 rook d8 and
kind of hope that this knight doesn't
get to a good square
i like that one and what about
uh sorry uh what about you
ah maybe trickier that would have been
that would have been maybe that's a
better move
ah but maybe king is seven i'm in time
to play rocket shade
ah thank you eliminating this dagger
absolutely wow
wow okay that's that's nice thank you
you will not check but now with king g7
rook d rook d8
white does want to play knight e4 and
then rook d2
that's a big threat yeah also by the way
white threatens knight
g5 if the knight gets to e4 right
knight g5 will just take the h pawn on
h3 yes exactly
so white is so hold on black that was
the pain
pay a little attention because white
might also play
g5 and drop a little knight f6
unstoppable mate action on you
if you're not paying attention this
could drop the block
whatever he wants but yeah there's
always a perp
yeah the thing about this position is we
should probably point to the audience
we've been talking about the move rook
f2 pretty often
but rook f2 here doesn't actually
threaten the checkmate
although how do you defend the pawn
maybe i go
um how do you defend this phone
i don't think i do actually um maybe you
play king g1 and start saying okay
let's breathe with the king but
jenna sing the f3 pawn doesn't really
bring a lot of relief either i mean
white's king is still in this
very unfortunate entanglement i mean
if nothing alpha is zero right your
knight's far away let's play 94 anyway
so you can play there yeah that or
knight f2 i wasn't sure
you're knight g5
threatening mate again yeah it's very
annoying
i mean it really is at alpha zero
pawn on h6 pawn on h3
is coming back to haunt so
we are currently in this situation king
g7
and what we've tried has not been that
satisfying we have just looked at the
rook d8 and convinced ourselves
that rook f2 advantage black
big advantage black but is there another
move
alternative well rook d8 played by the
way
rook d8 on the board yeah okay thank you
i don't see another plan for black
that's not rook f2 here
no i mean the rook had done it has done
its job on g2 it
forced the king into the corner the
knight on b2 needs
to return and
the knight on b2 does temporarily and
unfortunately guard
the d3 square so let's let's take
advantage of that and play rook f2
well that's a pond though right yeah
that's what it's going to be
yeah it's a it's a pawn and nepal will
push this forever
a good pawn guys i have to say i mean
these scores are just
i mean i i'm blown away by fabi's
defeat by mvl somehow being in the mix
still
it's it's like i'm staggered i
i mean the only guy who's been
consistent has been nepo
who's the most inconsistent player when
we talked about at the very start of the
candidates and you talk about mercurial
players you're
nepo's the very definition of somebody
who's
quite capable of running up a monster
score and then
you know inflicting a self wound if you
will
what move number are we on we are on
a uh he's the last four more moves to
make right
moves five minutes left yeah
the time control is yes the time
control's moving still an outside chance
for nepo here
outside yeah i mean
it's it looks like real to me
very real to me as well uh how
is
but we have with us the man of the hour
he has defeated fabiano corona and with
the black pieces
currently in first place it's anish giri
you must be feeling top of the world
um no yeah top of the world underneath
nepal yeah
so far uh take us through his
uh anish from from the get-go how uh
how were you feeling yeah i was a bit uh
i'm not sure i did that well i thought i
should um i tried to get my knight on e5
but i think it was not so
it was quite dubious at some point i
think
uh and then he got he went for this
before b5 was was maybe a little bit
rushed
um yeah now i was pretty optimistic
were you afraid of anything that was not
before b5
uh no i thought before b5 is super
strong um i thought knight a4
felt 94 or b3 i don't know but i thought
b4b5 was very strong but i have this
move
queen of eight which is also very good
after queen f8 i'm kind of uh
kind of in control uh kind of fine
surprisingly
and then once i'm fine you know i have
some trumps i have this knight on e5
and uh yeah it made a made a difference
in the end
well now one more moment i think richard
krishnan was after knight g6
i think he he's still not worse at all
he has either bishop d5 or bishop g4
bishop d2 was a little passive now i
unwind my pieces are
covered in the initiative i was still
yeah i was not
yet um uh optimist i mean i was fine but
i was not yet thinking that i am
taking over but after bishop 2 i was
already playing for an er for advantage
yeah i've got h6 i trade these bishops
it's very unpleasant for him
very unpleasant he wasn't able to find a
plan and it just seems you
hammered it in yeah uh it's a standard
you're a pro
position yes you want to be there okay
you're approaching the game today you
played a sicilian it's something that
you've been adding to your repertoire
it didn't seem like you needed to force
the game at any point but did you go
in saying look a draw is fine or did you
really think
it's time to score some points
uh well i won yesterday um
as well but i think
uh as much depends on me as it depends
on the leader here
so uh you know it is
better to make a drawing and young
toulouse than for both of us to win
right
so uh in that sense um yeah it was not
so
not so clear what would happen uh of
course uh
yeah so i wasn't sure if i'm in a must
win or not but uh
i just tried to give fabiano a chance to
play i didn't want to you know play the
berlin maybe and
uh depress him i thought he's in a must
win i am maybe also in sort of a must
win
i will give him a sicilian give him an
interesting position to play
and we'll play that um you know i'm not
going to be the party party poopers
yasser says well the other was the one
that was telling us you got to give your
opponent some rope right
yeah of course i mean if you if you want
to
play for a win with black you cannot
really play foreign black but you can
allow white to play for a win
and that's the first step perhaps
i turning our attention to the game of
napo the current position
on the board if i can pick your brain a
little bit here anisha
what's your first impression 93.92 yeah
93.92 is a draw um well maybe maybe
knight d2 is a draw
i think the i think how i might have
found okay
i need i need your uh bar there to be
sure but i think how much
that's cheating
[Laughter]
no bar after the game is not cheating
hard during the game is cheating
this is fine it's fine but it's okay
uh of course jan will play some other
move although there is knight c4 there
is
rookie three there is a bunch of moves
i don't know it's it could be lost but
uh rooker 4 i have knight f2 rooker 4 is
not a good move
but knight c4 or um
yeah rook e3 the move you made that's
also not so not so dumb
perhaps but i do like the king in the
cage though i do like the king
how is knight c4
rookie three by the way played already
by napo
yeah we are not yet in uh
we are not in the win loss territory yet
i think it's still um
ongoing you know um i think
the game is still continuing uh
definitely jan is
maybe jen is winning i don't know maybe
he's winning at the very least it's not
a draw
at the very least not a draw but uh he
could be already winning what do you
guys think
could be winning he could be winning my
first knee-jerk reaction is it's a win
because of the pawn on h3 and the weak
the vulnerable king but that's not your
problem
your problem is you've got two games
remaining you've given yourself an
enormous
opportunity and we just want to say
thank you for
sharing some time with us and to wish
you really
great luck in your remaining two games
absolutely thank you good luck thank you
thank you anish gary what an
amazing performance here in the second
half
of the tournament round robin number two
if you were to call it like that
look at that a plus three score
in the last five rounds guys that's what
it takes
to challenge magnus carlsen i mean he
had his critics but
the haters are turning into fans i got
to tell you something
you put that kind of score up
boy that is from a chess
that's lighting it up guys that's just
an amazing score i think
that's like what a 100 result over these
last
eight games or so last five especially
three wins
out of five he's gained 15 and a half
rating points he's not number four in
the world just a
whisper behind nepo we should point out
uh
nepo being number three fabio of course
number two he's having
the star tournament right now but let's
get that board up so we can
talk and keep watching because wang khao
is in time pressure and this is the
the game let's not let go of the board
uh we have the move rook e3 knight g3
played wang khao with four minutes
to make move 60 that shouldn't be too
difficult
but he is under pressure though knight
g3
although from the moment the g-pawn is
barely alive um that pawn on g4 looks
looks like scrumptious tempting
this looks this looks like a tough
position depot could win this
of course it changes the tournament
everything again
wow i mean i just feel like we're
watching
you know different models like
they have these computer models what
would happen in 25 000
you know uh universes and then
suddenly you go oh that's an interesting
universe let's go there
and every round seems to bring out new
possibilities and
for anish gary's fans uh this has just
been
wow i can't really ask for more right no
yeah
how is it wow three out of five one out
of five
beating probably with black wow
that's a magnusian result
if you will magnusian i mean he's
fabulous
and he's road ahead two players who lost
today both grishtrook and alexenko lost
today
so they're not feeling great about their
tournament richard now is mathematically
eliminated
100 and alexenko not playing well as
we've seen
some bad games for his level uh
anisha's got to be looking at chops and
if not him at least
his his handlers are thinking okay we
just got to keep him doing the same
don't mess with whatever the formula is
they're doing right now
we've got to keep doing the same thing
more of this
should net him the fabulous result
but nepo and nepal bring it that's the
question
right can nepal bring it can never kill
the face
i mean i'm just like no this would be
amazing if it came down to that
first game of the first round nepal
wanted a great game everybody said very
nice
yeah very nice you know but could it be
the
that could it be that that's the
tie-breaking result
that uh gives the challenger to nepo
it's amazing it's amazing guys by the
way rook a3
on the board uh setting up for knight
and rook uh a1 and
one more move to time period that looks
like a really good move
looks like a really good move uh to my
eyes i like this move a lot as i'm
seeing knight d3
and rook has to go to ea
as the threat what am i supposed to do
how do i meet that your work has to
have access goes to e8
the knight goes to d3 i'm threatening
well knight f1 can always
down brook
jeez thank you
knight f1 but is that what you want
you tell me what i'm doing there's not
nothing about this position is what you
want
it's what you want no you're not you're
not happy
you're united and yeah this is about
and let some fine
let's cement that night and
what what what why we have a breaking
news what's what
wang how didn't see a move and he
resigned what he did not see
his move he's resigned the game
wait what no are you serious it is over
and nepo
maintains his half a point lead which is
we know is an effective
one-point lead over geary despite this
fantastic
result by geary it may not be enough as
the runaway train of yan i'm sorry
i'm sorry what he resigned he resigned
well what do you do if you don't play
rookie eight but you play rookie
[Laughter]
we're grand masters i mean come on
i mean you're upon down it's ugly i get
it i get it i get it but this is not
resigns this is like
okay i mean i'm gonna play to some
bitter bitter
losing position resigns what
that's a stunning result what or was it
a clock no
no oh yeah time no what
oh i'm confused uh yes the position is
bad
very bad uh losing probably possibly
but why resign i mean you
your opponent should should should still
force
show you the is his victory shouldn't he
yes
absolutely that's resignation
too soon that is premature by far
guys our first four-zero uh
round and what a time for it to happen
the day before the free day
the tournament has just become
crazy help well actually with a win
the tournament has actually changed yeah
cause nepo has a full point ahead over
the only person that can catch him
correct i need well and yet wait a
minute
mvl he has a technical full point ahead
technical
but he has a real full a real one and a
half point
like what's the score nbl is down a
point
we probably have the standings it
doesn't matter if the network isn't
counted we can we can map it out
um if we can just be shown because what
i'm saying is
a win by here's so here we go
mean he's a point and a half of his head
of him point and a half
ahead of mvl that's the number he's not
a
he's a he's a on a technicality he's a
point ahead of geary because he beat
gary he has to draw odds
yeah right so he has draw odds against
gary but the key is that
mvl has to beat him right
and geary has to win
not for he needs to be challenger he's
got to win it clear
he's got to try to draw he can't he
can't draw and then have the same result
as
as nepo mvl with the black pieces
has to beat nepo nepo
and gary has to not lose but
draw or win against grishard and he
needs
mvl to to come through and look at that
one two six with a man by the way nepal
will be
very motivated to draw this game hyper
motivated to draw and as far as anish is
concerned
anish is in anish is in a must-win
situation tomorrow period
again tomorrow is his three days he must
win
and he will have some chances against
alexsenko but against grishchurch he's
hoping gristrick is
is torpedoing right now uh aneesh
must be grisham tomorrow
a draw and a prayer will not help
because the problem is if he draws and
nepo draws
the game the tournament's over well
it's then it's actually over he'll be a
half a point behind
it'll be a draw nepal will hit eight and
a half
well it means get nepal would have to
lose
he would have to lose to the right it's
possible it's because that's two tough
opponents maxime and dingler
it's possible nepo could lose a game
network would lose in one of the next
two
so it's not over it actually isn't over
nepo could lose one of the next two
games
anisha has to win one and nepo has to
lose one that's actually not that severe
it's still a tournament they're the only
two who could do it though right oh yeah
yeah
i mean mvl he has to win
then things have to happen lots would
have to happen
well guys i got to tell you we've got
two tension-filled rounds
to go in this tournament to determine
the challenger to magnus carlson
and i've got to say uh guys
this is the kind of action that we
commentators
live for four out of four you can't do
better than that
well guys remember tomorrow is a rest
day so don't
tune in everybody will be preparing for
their games to be played on monday
that's game 13
crucial round of course for
the leaders but also mvl if he still
wants to
say have a say in this tournament i'm
sure he'll prepare heart try to beat
nepalniacci with the black pieces
wow guys what what wow i'm still a
little [ __ ]
i'm a shell shark that he reassigned to
me i know
i i can't get over that another hour
i was you know i was thinking maybe no
brunch today yeah
yeah table based yeah
exactly interesting well saturday
sad day for american fans and fans in
many places in the world who like
fabiano caruana's play he is officially
eliminated there is a imagine
i mean is it is it 100
official it would require a full-scale
collapse by all the time
three tournament leaders but two of them
play each other
yeah don't don't even try so i'm trying
to figure out how it would work
i think maybe he's not mathematically
out actually
he's not mathematically out because nbl
could win and lose
he would have to win both games mvl
could win and lose nepal would have to
lose both
and anish would have to also do
something
horrible so maybe there's a one percent
somewhere math
chance for fabi yeah that would work out
that's all that needs to happen right
yeah
right all right wait a minute just a
second fabi would have to
win both of his games that would give
him eight points jan would have to
lose both of his games anish
would have to only score a half a point
no l
has to win against nepo
do better than a win better than a draw
raw
actually we could have a four-way tie
for first and then see the time break
i i am fabi's biggest fan and you guys
need to stop
you guys need to stop let's just call it
let's call it point zero three percent
all right mission impossible
the bettors will give you uh a hundred a
hundred thousand a one
okay maybe not that severe that's a bad
that's a bad bet
but mvl is in it if he beats nepo
yep he's got i mean that's his last
chance he's gotta that's gonna be a big
game
well guys remember uh we do have more
chess coming up in the summer as the
grand chess tour
returns we have uh romania will be the
first stop before
uh the granchester with the classical
super bad uh june 3rd to the 15th
and it will be immediately followed by
paris rapid and blitz of course in paris
france a classical
stop in the grand chess tour ever since
it's
actually not his inception but in the
first few years croatia rapid and blitz
changing up the format in 2019 it was a
classical event
now they're going to rapid and blitz and
we'll wrap up the grand chester this
year
in saint louis with the st louis rapid
and blitz followed of course
by the sink field cup which we love so
much absolutely
and we will see you not tomorrow tune in
on monday same time we'll be here
commentating crucial games who will
challenge magnus carlsen
later this year only two days to find
out thank you all for joining us we'll
see you on monday
[Music]
you